le youtube le ce que vous m'entendez
dans le 4l
de vie voire à diminuer le stress que
vous m'entendez dans le quatre oui c'est
bon ok nickel bas bonjour moi et pas
encore exactement 17 heures dimanche à
dreux devrait pas commencer avant que
tout le monde arrive de sécurisation
d'un qui bat bonjour et bienvenue
aujourd'hui on attend 17 heures il est
tranquillement en attendant que des gens
arrivent petit à petit
aux cassettes salut à tous
ok donc aujourd'hui on va parler du coût
de la théorie de l'information de claude
shannon ont parlé de quelques trucs que
je trouve vraiment très cool pour avoir
cette théorie la théorie de
l'information c'est assez rare en
belgique bon j'ai entendu parler cours
de mes études
et puis mais j'ai jamais eu de cours sur
le territoire formation et un jour j'ai
voulu dire
voulant savoir plus libre plutôt que de
lire les livres de cours je vais lire
shannon et vous l'avez lu l'article
original de claude shannon et ça m'a
vraiment bouleversée c'est ça a été un
bouleversement peuvent pas juste
mathématiquement mathématiquement
voilier truc très joli ça marche très
très bien mais je pensais plus
philosophiquement plus alliés quelque
chose d'incroyablement profond dans ses
idées de shannon et est en fait c'est
très lié au paysagisme ans et on creuse
un petit peu on se rend compte que c'est
enfin la théorie de l'information en ce
moment c'est une façon d'analyser les
probabilités et comment tel que la tour
est plus fondamental de l'information ça
y est la théorie des probabilités
et pour ça j'ai découvert bien plus tard
il est encore tôt pour en arriver là
voilà donc je suis assez à production
d'autant que les gens arrivent et en
fait on va commencer rapidement avec un
quiz
on peut avoir pas mal de cuisine
normalement j'ai dit cuisse de prévu du
coup la question qui suit c'est combien
de travailleurs et se lier fois je
croyais à 10h30 ce avait duré presque
trois heures que dieu je profite
d'ailleurs pour naître aujourd'hui mais
qu'elle s'arrête durée c'est dur et
enfin ça a duré moins de trois heures à
priori oui décidément pas trop longue et
beaucoup de choses à dire si ça dure rue
du nord ça serait une heure et demie on
va dire ça serait bien donc là il y aura
des crises au fur à mesure et
ça c'est le premier donc imaginé un jeu
vous avez un tas de balle et une camille
albane 1000 boul
pas mille dollars il ya mille balles et
à chaque étape en fait vous pouvez faire
des groupes de trois balles et demandé
aux maîtres du jeu ou au présentateur
ici dans quel paquet de balle se trouve
la bonne balle ligne bâle gagnante et
une balle gagnante qui a été choisi par
par le maître du jeu vous en avez 1000
il ya une parmi 1000 et à chaque chaque
étape vous pouvez diviser d'ensemble des
mille balles en trois groupes et demandé
au maître du jeu dans quel groupe se
trouve la balle en question la question
c'est si on se donne six étapes dieu
cirque on a droit de faire six fois
c'est à ces trois groupes de balle et
demandé aux maîtres du jeu à chaque fois
où se trouve la bonne balle parmi
l'élite soit 1 si on a le droit de faire
ça si fois est-ce que ça suffit pour
être garantie après après tout cela de
pouvoir trouver la balle gagnante
c'est le premier cuisez donc pour y
répondre
vous avez un lien ici qui
qui que vous pouvez taper alors j'ai mis
six dans la description de la vidéo pour
ceux qui veulent faire cliquez pas non
plus trop difficile à écrire enfin si
vous êtes sur son téléphone je me prends
clint de cliquer c'est peut-être un peu
galère chômage qui a pratiquement trois
ou dix ans sur le téléphone pour
attaquer vous pouvez aller voir sur ça
et donc si je vais sur le lien ça fait
devrait étonner sur un google forme donc
comme la dernière fois premier live
je vous demande des réponses
probabilistic le set est cochée c'est à
dire c'est que justement c'était que
j'écris et c'est pas la bonne affluence
l'échelle en fait tout à droite c'est
que la réponse est oui d'après vous qui
la question existe-t-il une stratégie
pour garantir contre contre une bonne
gagnante
si vous répondez répondait dit si vous
êtes sûr que la réponse est oui si vous
répondez 0 c'est que vous êtes sûr que
la réponse est non et au milieu si vous
êtes
c'est un certain que vous êtes à droite
que vous pensez que la réponse est
probablement oui plus est à droite que
penser que la réponse est probablement
non
et c'est la notation sera un qcm enfin
coco mais qcm bayésiens donc ces
notations quadratique pour les détails
c'est à dire que si vous pencher du
mauvais côté vous aurez des points
négatifs
et si vous pouviez beaucoup du mauvais
côté vous aurez des points très
rapidement très très très négatif alors
que dès que vous pourrez brancher un peu
de bon côté bon bah voilà vous avez déjà
pas mal de pont et vous ne gagnez pas
beaucoup beaucoup plus de points à
mettre 10 sur 10 par rapport à 9 sur 10
si la réponse était oui je vous laisse
réfléchir à cette question alors je
reviens sur le texte tout ça moi je peux
voir recevoir les réponses
je voulais aussi voulu mettre une petite
musique
[Musique]
il est 80 av a répondu jusque là
continuer avec moi
est-ce que six étapes suffisent
[Musique]
un cairote passé sont passés sans et
concerne à 96 réponse sans réponse allez
plus qu'une réponse assez basses et a
passé sans réponse pour avoir les
réponses c'est la ccvo réponse comme ça
continue continue à répondre vous vous
êtes très partagés
c'est visiblement il ya sept pas trop au
centre n'est quand même pas mal de gens
trop extrêmes donc ça c'est pas tip top
c'est à dire qu'il ya une bonne portion
en travaux qui vont voir complètement
tort malheureusement donc si je regarde
la moyenne comme ça donc j'ai sur pas
d'outils pour calculer automatiquement
la moyenne mais à la louche j'ai
l'impression que ça penche quand même
légèrement du côté du côté non mais pas
beaucoup à dire que ça fait 4 en moyenne
dans ça veut dire quoi que vous dites 4
en moyenne
si vous dites 4 en moyenne ça voudrait
dire j'aime bien sûr sur noir donc ça
ces annotations donc quand on a vu la
dernière fois la notation donc c'est les
courbes la courbe bleue que vous voyez à
l'écran c'est la courbe de vos notes si
la réponse est non si la réponse est non
et qui est vous avez répondu 0 marqué 10
points ça
ça j'avais pas normalisées et moi je
fais un truc plus jolie ctions fait
d'échanger en temps réel ce que
jean-louis de tizor qu on se fait avoir
bien enregistré en fait non
qui
et pour que ça fasse 10 pour un maximum
[Musique]
4 ok donc là les cours de vos points
ok et donc si vous avez répondu 4 6 6
pour ceux qui ont répondu 0 par exemple
si vous avez répondu 0 à cette question
et que la réponse est non alors donc c
est folle et vous marquer 10 points
mais si vous avez réussi réponse est
vrai alors que oui alors que vous avez
répondu 0 vous perdez 30.7 -30 donc là
vous avez répondu en moyenne quatre mois
je veux voir vérifier que ça n'a pas
trop changé c'est le zéro a pris de
l'ampleur à tout à coup vous êtes
beaucoup plus avoir 10 0 bien que la
moyenne a l'air maintenant deux points
chez un peu plus on va dire que vous
avez dit 3 en moyenne
si aussi l'arrêt conseiller en effet le
nom qu'on le pensait le croire dit
clairement marqué six points donc c'est
pas loin de ce fascinant de 10
mais si la réponse est vrai alors vous
perdez presque 10 points alors que pour
le savoir faites tout ça c'est essayer
avant de vous donner réponse de m
un tour de magie assez connu peu de
magie mais c'est le prime si on a nagé
27 carte et je vais les manger mais
manger et on va dire que imaginons que
le problème ça va être d'identifier le
joker un joker rouge puis un joker rouge
dans le tas qui est vraiment il ya un
joker rouge si j'ai bien préparé tricot
la hiérarchie à rouge qui est là qui est
un jeu qui a rouge dans le tas une plage
de mélange sait pas où il est on va
imaginer que je suis le joueur donc
séquence équivalent des bonnes je sais
pas où il est et il ya un maître yeux
par contre qu'il va me dire ou es ce
qu'il est dans le si je fais trois tard
une carrière je vais faire les 3 tab
c'est très simple je fais c'est comme ça
je fais thierry carte comme ça les
autres et on va demander aux maîtres du
jeu de nous dire où se trouve le joker
rouge petite ville
imaginons kalou de lemaître lieu bave
admettre jeu allez donc si vous demande
dans quel état se trouve le carreau il
est obligé de dire ce talent et
maintenant pour pour faire ressortir le
joker rouge ce que je vais faire c'est
par son camp c'est fait la mère s'est
fait le tour de magie c'est que on est
au milieu ensuite on recommence on fait
un nouveau trois tas
demande où est le joker rouge ou maître
du jeu et le maître du jeu va nous dire
ce talent là encore on au milieu et on
refait sa une dernière fois qu'on retire
les 25 cartes évidement maîtres du jeu
tu nous indiquer dans quel état se
trouve le joker rouge
vous avez peut-être vu passer qui se
trouvent dans cet art a donc nommé au
milieu hélas ce qui se passe c'est que
la carte du milieu donc si je fais mon
il ya 27 48 m
treize cartons côté un peu 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 et vraiment la 14e carte
pour tous c'est le local rouge et donc
donc là comme ça on peut dire c'est un
peu surprenant un vieux carouge s'est
retrouvé au milieu du but alors que
l'impression de pas forcément ça
s'appelle savait pas l'air garantie une
autre façon de comprendre un peu ce qui
s'est passé ici c'est que à chaque étape
en fait lorsqu'on oublie parce que le
maître du jeu nous dit où est le joker
rouge
bah en fait techniquement on pourrait
supprimer les deux premiers tas si le
jeu qui nous dit que joker rouge et la
fête on pourra oublier ces deux cas donc
si sauf quand il a mis au dessus et en
dessous
je vais je vais séparés dans la main
dans cette étroite à et lorsque je
remets les cartes
en fait une fois qu'ils en fait j'ai
étalé le premier et a gelé j'ai étalé
sur les 3
en fait j'aurais pu faire ça séparément
interdit était allé juste aller
si le tas du mieux on sait qu'il ya le
joker rouge après il restera neuf cartes
qui seront un peu mis fin si c'est
pareil que les neuf premières c'est un
peu comme si elle était allée k en fait
les neuf premières et neuf derniers en
fait ces dons se retrouver toujours au
début à la fin et du coup c'est comme si
elle ne comptait pas donc je m d'une
viable le karoubi dans ce terrain nous
de la même façon si on redistribuait
mettrait au milieu fait les premières
cartes il sera éliminé d'emblée des
dernières aussi se réunit et l'anglais
est la fin c'est comme si on me
demandait juste sur ces trois cartes qui
restent ou et le joker rouge et les
maîtres du jeu nous dit qu'ils valent
mais au milieu et en gros il y avait
déjà toutes ces cartes ont calé au
milieu du paquet ayant fait les toutes
les cartes avant qu'ils ont été enlevés
qui vont être au dessus les autres en
dessous en dessous et du coup le bloc
herbe c'est sans surprise qui se
retrouve au milieu
alors donc ce tour de magie là comme ça
on va le savoir la variable clé qui fait
que ça marche c'est que j'ai pu faire
des tas qui sont bien séparées à chaque
fois ça ça c'est pas de nulle part ça
vient du fait qu'il ya 27 cartes et
qu'il faudra que ça tu es ici important
puisque 27
vous pouvez vérifier sur vos
calculatrices ces 3 x 3 x 3 c3 au cube
en fait à chaque étape on a écarté en
gros deux tiers des cartons
la réduit l'ensemble des candidats par
trois et du coup c'est la première étape
27 été visé par trois et un cx 9 est la
deuxième étape 9 a été divisé par trois
et spéculent 3 est la dernière étape 3
exigés par trois il restait plus qu'une
carte était la bonne car alors une façon
donc ça c'est un raisonnement qui marche
bien une façon un peu plus informations
théorie théorie de l'information qu'il
pourrait expliquer ça qui consiste à
réfléchir à quelle est la quantité
d'informations que l'on gagne à chaque
étape et il se trouve que lorsque l'on à
ce qu'on fait trois tas si on fait trois
thèmes qui sont tous aussi probable les
uns que les autres
pauvre pour une raison sur laquelle on
va revenir plus tard
mais précisément
problème avec sais pas pourquoi
petit problème technique
tu sous peu ce tir
[Musique]
je peux prouver ni le pas
donc
faire sa part texte temporairement
soutien désolé donc en fait non d'un
point de vue théorique d'information il
se trouve que on gagne une quantité qui
s'appelle le log en base 2 2 3 bits
d'information par étapes
alors pourquoi est-ce que l'ogre en
baisse de 2,3 on va revenir un peu plus
sur sûr ça plus tard mais donc le locle
à base d'eau ça vient du bit donc c'est
que qu'a voir avec le fait que les
choses sont binaires et le 3 vient du
fait qu'il ya trois cas et c'était
étroite a été plus probable on n'avait
aucune idée de se trouver le joker par
exemple où les balles en question et du
coup le nombre de bits d'information de
kong gagne à chaque fois ces îles sauf
que c log en baisse de 2,3 donc c'est
vraiment on va clarifier tout ça au fur
et à mesure et le truc c'est que
initialement l'incertitude que l'on a
donc appelé la hache mais on verra plus
en détail ce que ça signifie plus tard h
c'est le lot gambas 2 du nombre de
boules qui avait initialement
donc si on regarde dans tout l'espace
public égal aux gambas de 2000 et donc
ça on peut le calculer
donc je peux sur desnos
j'utilise un truc s'appelle des semences
pour faire ses calculs bon voilà donc si
on fait le log en baisse de 2,3 ça me
fait 25 50 8 bits d'information à chaque
étape et si on regarde l'entropie donc h
ici qui est égal
initial log en base de 2009 et 9,1 mais
du coup la question pour savoir si six
étapes ne suffiront c'est de savoir si
on peut acquérir suffisamment
d'informations avec six états qu'avec
six étapes bas à chaque étape on
additionne en fait l'information comme
on gagne donc à chaque étape
en fait on gagne blog en baisse de 2,3
du coup au bout de six étapes on gagne
log en base de 2 3 bits d'information et
là on voit que six fois l'ogre base 2 de
3 c'est égal à 9,5 qui est inférieur à
l'entropie initial c'est-à-dire
l'incertitude qu'on avait initialement
donc six étapes en fait ne suffisent pas
à réduire cette information à 0 or il
faut la réduire à zéro une information
réduite à zéro c'est à dire qu'il a plus
aucune certitude
et pour être sûr de gagner fouquet où
plus aucune incertitude
ce raisonnement en termes de curry
d'information montre qu' il n'y a pas ou
peu pas il n'y a pas assez
d'informations que l'on peut récupérer
avec six étapes pour pouvoir résoudre ce
problème
toutes les réponses étaient non six
étapes ne suffisent pas bien sûr il ya
des des raisonnements un peu plus à la
main qu'on peut faire en se disant que
chaque chèque avec six étapes
en fait on peut identifier une boule
parmi trois puissants 6 finalement et
trois puissants 6 si je fais le calcul
ça me fait 729 et donc ça suffit pas
donc ça c'était une petite application
très pratique très simple de comment à
ce que l'intérêt d'information adresse
de ce problème
même si bon il ya des solutions qui
n'utilise pas un terril informations qui
sont les plus directs pour pouvoir y
arriver
ça me permet aussi de faire une petite
remarque rapport à la dernière fois les
nerfs fois je vous ai posé une énigme et
espère foiré
vous avez fait le juste prix j'avais
négligé le cas où juste prix maître du
jeu un chiffre en tête et on donne un
monde et nous dit plus grand ou plus
petit est en fait j'avais considéré
vraiment ce problème là alors que le
vrai juste prix c'est le maître du jeu
plus répondre oui c'est le bon prix il
me semblait que çà çà çà çà çà çà
changeait pas grand chose parce que la
propriété de tomber sur sa était faible
en fait si ça change énormément de
choses il se trouve que grâce à ça en
fait on peut hein aux tropiques on gagne
à cheval est beaucoup plus grande que
qques que si on a juste une réponse oui
ou non et ça suffit en fait si on à
nkouo on peut résoudre jusqu'à on peut
trouver un nombre parmi deux puissances
ennemies 1 2 puis en scène dans un ait
pas de puissance et mozart comme je le
pensais bref c'est une petite correction
par la première fois ok donc ça c était
une petite introduction par rapport à ce
problème
maintenant on va rentrer un peu plus
dans le coeur de la théorie de
l'information et maintenant je vais être
encore embêté par mon problème technique
et je sais peuple
il fait ça
on fait un mode précision
marchât nous donne ça
et c'est
je crois que c'est bon je crois que tu
as he is foutu en l'air mais ça a l'air
de marcher à nouveau
ok
[Musique]
ok je pense qu'on est beau du coup le
aujourd'hui donc on va voir un peu plus
la théorie de l'information et le
postulat fondamental de claude shannon
qui est vraiment le postulat qui permet
de tout déroulait ensuite c'est le fait
que l'information d'un message m est
égal à log en baisse de 2,1 sur la
probabilité du message
m
ça peut pas très très bizarre dit comme
ça pour avoir une intuition de ce que
veut dire shannon par là je vais prendre
l'exemple de deux mondes de deux mondes
de mon prénom par exemple si on prend le
prénom les vous mon prénom complet
relais nguyen de se demander est-ce que
ou juste dans l'est c'était plus
intéressant juste sanction il réussit
est-ce que le mollet contient beaucoup
d'informations et une réponse annaïck de
base ça serait de dire ben laissé deux
lettres
donc c'est assez peu d'informations
c'est moins d'informations que le mot
chat par exemple qu'il ya 4 et après on
pourrait se dire ça mais une des
réflexions qui je me suis fait après
avoir les jeunes qui a vraiment
clarifier nommément des choses on
réfléchit ensemble cette équation c'est
une dire en fait la quantité
d'informations de l'expression les c'est
pas sinon c'est finalement pas seulement
ça dépend pas seulement de l'est du
mollet seulement ses dépens en fait sans
doute pas mal du contexte du mexique au
vietnam il ya beaucoup de gens qui
s'appellent les choses comme ça et du
coup quand on dit les a faits x glide
l'effet des basses par exemple c'est pas
ce pack r de qui on parle puisqu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de les différents
différents et du coup la quantité
d'information du mollet au vietnam par
être plus faible que en france inverse
en france il ya très peu de gens qui
s'appellent les et du coup le mollet
contient beaucoup plus d'informations il
permet beaucoup plus d'identifier une
chose lève beaucoup plus d'ambiguïté du
coup l'information du mollet est
beaucoup plus grande
est ce que dit chan c'est que la zone
pour laquelle cette intuition et est
juste c'est que la quantité
d'informations d'un mot dépendent à quel
point il est rare si c'est un mot qu'on
utilise tous les jours
bah finalement c'est un mot qui disait
dans tellement de contexte que bondues
plus beaucoup d'informations al'inverse
un mot qui est assez rare
tout ce qui est assez inhabituel va être
beaucoup plus conduit à aller voir un
message beaucoup plus pro enfin
percutante à dire remarquable est en
fait d'après chez dams et ça aura plus
d'informations et donc intuitivement
selon shannon plus la probabilité d'un
message est faible si p2m est très très
très faible alors le message contient
plus d'informations alors à côté de ça
il est relié à votre truc qui est log et
il se trouve que le log en base de aux
particuliers ça beaucoup d'applications
pour plus tard particulier on verra plus
tard pourquoi est-ce que le log et la
base de son de samson g on coule on
participe en particulier en fait ça va
permettre vraiment l'addition on a envie
de dire que si on donne deux
informations qui sont qui ont rien à
voir son pardon d'antan particulier bas
lorsqu'on combine ces deux informations
on a deux fois plus d'informations que
chacun des morceaux de l'information le
log c'est vraiment ce qui permet cette
intuition lots gambas 2 2 il y ait au
codage binaire doute on parlera tout à
l'heure ok donc pour avoir de continuer
on va passer à un quiz
j'essaie de faire des cuiseurs assez
régulièrement pour pour vous occuper
pour vous réveiller ou pour vous occuper
ses sous
donc le quiz 2 donc pour y accéder
donc savez je suis remplacé par deux
bit.ly s4 alive q2 et donc la question
c'est or c'est rien à voir avec les
maths
enfin vous pu avoir une question plus
empirique mais si le peuple se détendre
c'est la question plus de 35% des
vietnamiens ont pour nom de famille
nguyen est ce que vous pensez que c'est
vrai parce que c'est faux donc ça alors
j'ai eu du mal à trouver des chiffres
voire en fiable donc la bonne réponse
est pas allé j'ai vu des estimations qui
sont assez éloignées de 35% suffisamment
éloigné pourquoi cette question nous
paraît assez une réponse on va dire
assez assez fiable qu'est ce que vous
pensez à ce que la tendance est plutôt
oui ou plutôt dont et ce qui est
intéressant dans un an nous pensions ou
suivez le lien c'est que du coup on
demande des réponses probabiliste du
coup ça vous force à décrire votre
incertitude concerne hier si vous
répondez au milieu c'est que l'entropie
de cette réponse est pour vous dans le
contexte dans lequel vous êtes encore
assez grand et j'apprendrai quelque
chose quand je vous donnerai la réponse
ainsi l inverse connaissez la réponse il
est sûr que c'est quelqu'un avec moi
alors vous êtes sûr aussi de ne rien
apprendre au moment où je vous donnerai
la réponse à cette question
[Musique]
la question plus de 35% des vietnamiens
c'est de bien décrire votre incertitude
c'est pas tant un exercice heures du mat
la formation c'est sur l'application
directe de l information savoir si vous
êtes capable de cuire les zones et avec
l'incertitude avec cette question
aiguillé
[Musique]
si vous voulez que je dise haut et ça
aussi c'est que c'est le moment puisque
c'est le moment je regarde parfois le
chat 10 c'est clairement oui 0 c'est
clairement non 5 c je sais pas trop vite
ça s'est plutôt mis 9 kg a quasi
clairement oui lui fasse un petit doute
et ainsi de suite
le son de ma voix est passé d'abord par
la musique ça tu repars normalement
j'ai bonne mine
je ne suis pas trop fatigué aujourd'hui
pas encore venir à 22h
ok on a passé les sans réponse
montrer ce que vous avez répondu non
plus vous êtes plutôt oui avec un peu
plus d'incertitudes que et des rares
fois si je devais dire la moyenne je la
mettrais à 7
là comme ça il ya quand même pas mal de
nombre de zéros absolument non voyez il
y aura au moins 10% d'entre vous qui
auront moins 30 points à cette question
c'est pas cool d'avoir moins 30 points
c'est une grosse pénalité mais qu'est
donc en ont donc ok bon bref derrière la
porte en tout cas déjà vu plusieurs
sources acquis qui suggérait que c'est
plus de l'ordre de 40% le nombre de
vietnamiens dont le nom de famille est
un duel et je parviens du nom de famille
à ce que voici mon prénom
du coup moi je me prend souvent la
remarque quand je dis mon prénom les
haines du yen et je prends toujours là
remarque donc je te vois tu de ton non
pas ton prénom
j'ai aussi des histoires marrante
d'enseignants qui qui m'ont enseigné à
écrire mon prénom de la mauvaise manière
vous avez répondu alors il ya de 7 à peu
près la louche ça vous fait plus 6,4 en
fête sa dixième fois que vous répondrez
que de marquer 6,4 points
donc si je vais garder un compte des
comptes des scores ça vous fait 13
points sur 20 au maximum et moi 60
minimum c'est pas mal c'est c'est pas
mal un peu des notations à la française
que dire que 13 sur 20 c'est pas mal
mais
c'est quand même c'est dévié par la
difficulté la question la question de
tétouan facile moi je sais pas je pense
que j'aurais été très incertain j'étais
très incertain je pense que j'aurais
répondu plutôt non mais ce serait plutôt
un peu trompé moi l'intelligence des
foules ans qui a fait mieux que moi ok
ok on va passer à la formule un peu plus
rigoureuse maintenant de la formule le
truc c'est que cette formule là en fait
elle est jamais enseigné comme ça ce que
je trouve très dommage en tout cas j'ai
rarement enseignée comme ça ce que j'ai
vu est est ce que je trouve dommage
parce que tard dans l'intuition que j'ai
donné c'est moi aussi ça m'a pas mal des
blocs aimante mais bon en prenant ça
en prenant en prenant cette définition
d'un déduit automatiquement
l'entropie alors l'entropie ici on va
parler on la compare à d'autres pays de
shannon est ce que mon lait qu'ils y ont
inventé une autre une autre une autre
valeur d'entreprise qui il a moins de
sens fait mais bon c'est fini siens que
les excuses à la hausse et c'est le plus
urgent c'est très profond dans l'idée
d'entraînement en théorie d'information
je suis aussi que la musique tout à
l'heure l'entropie tschannen c'est tout
simplement la quantité d'informations on
s'attend à observer c'est la quantité
d'informations de moyenne donc
l'entropie le chat donne on l'a notre
souvent h et donc h atteints d'un
message si on a un message m
on constate en recevoir l'entropie du
message qu'ont donc on va voir ça va
être égal à l'espérance que
l'information de m c'est la quantité
d'informations moyenne comprendre à se
voir et lorsque je prends le message qui
va être aléatoire et donc ça ça s'écrit
on peut réécrire espérances m du log
combas 2-1 sur la probabilité de m on
est quasiment jamais écrit comme ça on
va développer cette expression donc
l'espérance pour calcul espérance en
fait on fait la somme surtout les
messages
m
oui mais ça je dire qu'on a un ensemble
de messages et on va regarder donc la
valeur ici donc c'est le log baisse de 1
sur comité de m et on va pondérée par la
probabilité du message
m m après si vous prêtez que le message
m prennent la valeur p tit n voilà
probabilité que m est égal à petit elle
met d'entropie de shannon sa version
encore plus habituel on me dira c'est
donc si on pose pmd galles a profité que
m est égal à m l'entropie on peut la
réécrire comme la somme pour les m
appartenant aimeront sont des messages
de paix m le log en base 2 1 sur pn et
notre façon de l'écrire c'est de
remarquer qu'en fait de remarquer qu'en
fait ça c'est ça s'écrit aussi le moins
le log en base de 2pm cette propriété
que le log le log de base 2 7 me
rapporte quelles bases ce sera mal de
pain sur x c'est mon blog de x est donc
souvent on leur ai écrit aussi la somme
sur les m appartenant à m avec un mort
devant pm l'oeuvre en baisse de 2 pm ça
c'est la définition souvent que l'on
voit la plus la plus
vous voyez créé et écrit des choses ça
comme ça d'abord sur la vignette de
cette vidéo c'est cette équation que
j'ai écrit que j'ai écrite parce que
c'est utile à plus courte pas tout
simplement
c'est ça l'entropie et on peut faire
plusieurs choses pour pour mieux
comprendre cette entropie mais avant ça
je vais passer à un autre cuisent donc
le quiz 3 un peu de musique
depuis ce 3 on pose la question il peut
vous pouvez déjà y accéder
c'est quelque chose sur les logarithmes
donc peut-être que je devrais faire un
rappel avant c'est que en fait l'oeuvre
dire que l'oc ii en base à 2 b est égal
à ses souvenirs
ça veut dire que si je mets à à la
puissance x
j'obtiens ap
le titan le log en base de d'un nombre
le gambas de par exemple de 4 vos dires
de huit clos
le log en baisse de 2,8 c'est un nombre
x tel que si je mets de puissance x
j'obtiens 8,2 puissance knicks il ya 8
une solution qui eric segal tout ça
c'est pour la définition du coup la
question c'est lorsque je fais
est-ce que j'ai cette égalité là si je
prends le log en base à 2 b et jeux
multi vie sa part le log en basse b2 c
est ce que j'obtiens le log en base à 2
c
un peu à réfléchir à ça ça peut paraître
assez réfléchir donc le gant base à de
baisse
si je prends un nombre s'est passé un
nombre x tel que si je fais à puissance
x mpd et si je prends un nombre y tels
que b puissance y est égal c est ce que
ça me fait le nombre tel que si je fais
ap le nombre z quelques aussi le fait
absent aide c'est égal à c
je suis peut-être un peu plus difficile
malgré ce matin difficile mais il fait
réfléchir un petit peu il invite à
accélérer un papier un crayon c'est le
moment de sortir et de vous lancer dans
ce petit exercice
[Musique]
tout cas trois questions en 45 minutes
c'est parti pour durer
[Musique]
on
quadrivium après masse qui dit qu'elle
est plus simple plus simple que la
précédente je trouve je sens que c'est
une réponse de mathématiciens si vous
connaissez pas la chaîne
le podium très note très bien ça je suis
pas sûr d'être bien le français mais je
regarde très vivant comme une série sur
la géométrie projective qui en top
ouais aussi on va supposer que tous les
nombres ah ouais il faudrait que ouais
[Musique]
quoi de plus simple je cours et j'ai un
peu annoncé la conclusion d'un contre
abc street un peu encore
c'est l'été les ennuis avec ça
elle vous invite à réfléchir c'est
largement fins et trouvable il faut
juste réfléchir à poser quelques ça peut
prendre un peu de temps donc c'est
normal que c'est pas facile c'est un
média comme ça et mais c'est un exercice
intéressant en tout cas je vous invite à
essayer de jouer avec ça de réfléchir à
ce qui se passe
pour voir ces genres de manipulation qui
peut peut-être les décisions non
seulement trouver la réponse c'est
intéressant ce soit si c'est vrai
comprendre pourquoi c'est vrai souci
c'est faux pas comprendre pourquoi cette
eau et enfin le démontrer c'est une
chose et puis s'il veut vraiment le
comprendre de le sentir
c'est encore autre chose et en fait pas
que tu as fait connaître avec blue le
sait que cette expression est vrai j'ai
pas d'intuition très très très clair que
je sais que c'est que ça mais c'est
dentition que c'était quoi sont ils pas
vos fausses
je connais le résultat mais
encore du mal à me construire une bonne
intuition de gossas
j'ai passé un excellent
[Musique]
quelque chose ne peut passer aux
réponses petit à petit
je
oui
du coup plus
91 réponse à une tête à atteindre les
100 réponses 1 n'est pas très loin
et
e
les 96 réponse et encore quatre réponses
''six
et
c'est vrai c'est sans réponse moi qui a
plus que nous voici à quoi ressemblent
vos réponses très clairement ça penche
du côté
du oui très nettement et en plus
certains d'entre vous qui sont sûrs
d'eux et voit la réponse est oui au fait
en effet cette équation était valide que
pour abc ce n'est pas un polluant cure
je sais pas s'il y en a qui ont répondu
peu côté parce qu'ils ont supposé ab
sais pas ce que j'aurais pu avoir un
problème si un des trois régimes à
gimont ratier l'upa a fléchi à tous les
détails mais en tout cas si abc sens
strict en plus anxieux à la vacance est
oui alors à la louche j'en ai dire que
la moyenne ces deux autour de neuf on va
dire de ce que vous avez répondu avec
même si réponse neuf donc ça me fait 9,6
points quasiment 10
c'est vraiment cool vous fait 12 j avais
12.8 maintenant c'est plus 9,6 9.6 22 si
vous avez 6.4 pour la première réponse
si ce qu'on 4a deuxième et maintenant
vous avez 9.6 ce qui vous fait 22 points
sur 30
collectivement
alors en fait cette relation est assez
utile parce que parfois il ya des
calculatrices sûr qu'elle n'y a pas le
log en base 2 oui juste le l'aube et
l'aisne par exemple et donc le donc lm
pour ceux qui connaissent pas c'est le
log embase e hélène 2x cnnc le log bas
ceux de x et donc c'est donc c'est y
tels que de puissance y est égal à x
ça c'est vous trouverez souvent ça sur
des calculatrices et du coup si vous
pouvez calculer le log en base 2 log en
base de dunes price et p&o azor sans
abri qui arrive souvent à trouver
l'information
ils ont moins le log en baisse de 2 p ça
va être égal à moins donc comment la
manière dont moi en tout cas ça c'est
moi elle n 2 p / à nîmes 2 2 c'est un
peu la parure que je connais par coeur
donc pourquoi parce que donc on l'a vu
le log on base de 2,2 fois le log combas
de paix est égal aux log en base de deux
pays c'est bien équivalent les deux
lignes et du coup ford ka le trek a tapé
souvent dans les calculatrices
si vous n'avez pas le log en baisse 2
c'est c'est cette expression donc ça ça
se voit on peut le voir graphiquement
oublié de mettre sur des skis du sketch
boucle et donc ouais nan à cette
relation
ça c'est joli ans si vous agissez comme
relation ça fait une espèce de relation
de chasles pas pour passer 2e à 2 puis 2
2 ap c'est une chose que de passer 2 e
ap d'une certaine manière et sa sas
illustre assez bien avec ces histoires
de triangle de puissance et jeu
passionnés déjà entendu parler il craint
goal of power
donc si vous pouvez chercher sa sueur
sur youtube par exemple vous pouvez
googlers du tout les goûts dire sur
youtube
tu rigoles earth hour c'est
une vidéo de meilleure youtube heures de
maths au monde sur ce sujet fribourg
drogue qui fait la remarque que en
faites pas on a trois relations souvent
qu'on écrit de façon assez différent pas
un on a tendance à écrire de puissance 3
est égal à 8
a priori on voit ce que ça veut dire on
écrit aussi 8 est égal à racine cubique
de deux déjà le lien entre entre les
deux est pas très clair comment est-ce
qu'on passe de l'un à l'autre ça c'est
pas très bon on va dire qu'il ya un
niveau de notation et on écrit aussi que
le log en baisse de 2,8 égale à 3 et là
par contre ça se fait devant bizarre et
je suis donc quand j'ai vu ces histoires
de tringle reprendre la vidéo le frigo
en born me suis dit mais ça que huit
égale racine cubique de 2 et l'ogg en
baisse de 2,8 et gagnent 3 j'ai
l'impression que c'était deux égalités
différentes que ça paraît de deux
chaussures est en fait allé dans les
trois cas en fait on décrit une relation
entre 2 3 et 8 et donc ce que propose
free blue album c'est d'écrire au lieu
d'écrire ça pas de notation différente
d'apprendre un truc qui te dire que en
fait une relation entre 2 3 8 ce qui
correspond à ça donc ça serait une
espèce d'égalité c'est au lieu d'avoir
une égalité entre deux nombres il en a
une relation entre 3 3 nombre de 3,8 et
qu'il ya un lien prions le kili l'e3 du
coup dans ce cas là la relation de
chasles dit que pour passer de aa bel
exposants qui permet de passer de a à b
x l'exposant qui permet de passer de b à
c c'est égal à l'exposant qui permet de
passer de a à c
je trouve ça assez joli merci vous
cherchez un training europe avoir
rajouté cinq cents vols sur google vous
allez tomber sur un article de blog où
je parle de tout ça ce que je trouve ça
très cool donc j'invite un peu à la
société joue avec tout ça mais je me
rends compte qu'avec le fasse un peu
plus aussi parce que je n'ai pas une
compréhension très profonde de tout ça
oui c'est ça ça peut être utile pour
mieux me sentir ce qu'on entend par par
l'information est passée aux cuisses
suivant nouveau puise on va parti
directement avec la musique donc le
nouveau puise donc je suis con passé par
alors le nouveau cuisine dit que
l'entropie de deux variables est la
somme des anthropique des variables ce
que vous pensez que c'est vrai risque
qu'on sait que c'est faux quel point
est-ce que vous êtes sûr de vous est-ce
que l'entropie de deux variables et la
somme des entreprises des variables
h2x y égal à hdx plus h2y
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
neuchâtel
il
[Musique]
j'ai des discussions sur le log complexe
le complexe est un peu chiant c'est un
peu mal définie n'est ce pas trop mal
défini non plus faut bien tourner c'est
un peu compliqué
quelle est la définition de l'entropie
d'un couple de variables on a défini on
avait défini donc htx fait donc c'est
moi la sones
lason dpx 2x la probabilité lorsque son
imparable aléatoire quand 30x que ce
après l'avoir petit x fois le log en
base 2 de la propriété x du coup alto xy
bas c'est la même chose que c'est à la
somme et sa danse une somme donc à voir
est une somme surtout les x
sur google books maintenant si nous
sommes surtout toutes les paires xy
probabilité selon la loi conjointe xy
d'avoir xy fois le log en phase 2 de
projets it et xy
[Musique]
h ça me gêne c'est lente alpiq en
physique alors en effet je suis désolé
de ça c'est les méandres de l'histoire
bien chez soi pour presque l'entropie
s'appelle h par que shannon l'appeler à
chansons dans son article je passe une
histoire derrière ça montre une histoire
nazon marrante sûr qu'on vous
réfléchissez une histoire amarante sur
pourquoi ce que shannon ont appelé
l'entropie l'entropie ce qu'au début il
voulait appeler cette fonction vous
l'appelez incertitude la fonction
d'incertitude choses comme ça et john
von neumann qui est ce que j'avais
entendu parler de john donovan john
goodman c'est vraiment le la brutale des
maths et surtout de cette époque et 30
et d'épuiser les verts on va dire
et surtout années 30 40 et puis 50
compris les morts à ces jeunes
malheureusement s'est mise en mode saas
et john goodman lui avait dit je
conseille d'appeler la fonction entropie
plutôt que fonction d'incertitude ou
choses comme ça et il ya donné deux
raisons la première c'est que
premièrement en fait déjà été étudiée
plus ou moins d'un cas particulier a
déjà été étudié en physique en
particulier en thermodynamique par le
ludwig boltzmann sa première raison
c'est pierre deuxième raison est la plus
importante qui aurait ajouté
c'est que personne ne sait ce qu'est
l'entropie du coup dans un débat qui
aura toujours davantage c'est pas parce
que c'est le hamiltonien pour certains
systèmes mieux je pense pas que ça soit
ça
je sais pas trop parce que besoin d'où
il avait appelé est-ce donc si ici waouh
gibbs ici s'il avait voulu être plus
proche de bîmes je serai qu'elle est
très utile mais si elle voulait être
plus proche de la physique il doit
plutôt appeler s à vie c'est vraiment
moi je sais pas je sais pas devenir ce
match intéressant donc l'on copie de
deux variables et la somme des
entreprises est variable est ce qu'on a
acheté xy est égal à acheter x + hd y
est ce que les les entreprises
s'additionnent que qu'en pensez vous
l'entropie est préservée dans notre
puissance et en physique souvent
l'entropie c'est plus ce qui varie au
coût du système alors que le reste est
constant et femmes sous lois de la
thermodynamique qui dit que l'entropie
d'un système augmente d'un système fermé
c'est plus une mesure de ce qui bouge
que de ce qui reste des paiements la
mettre dans les systèmes à l'eee
keyboard et d'autres aussi si on
considère des échanges on peut avoir
d'autres d'autres sorte d'équilibré
exactement la même formule mais c'est la
formule le physique et celle de gips par
le bluesman faca particulier celle de
gibbs oui un simple est que les gars
aiment et 5 ghz album version plus
générale le contre-pied
plus
à 89 réponse c'est ce qu'ils peuvent
encore onze petites réponses pour qu'on
arrive à 100 avant que résonne la
réponse est ce que lorsqu'on prend deux
variables
seules des entreprises l'entropie jeu
l'ensemble des deux variables et est la
somme des entreprises des variables
91 réponse est
neuf encore réponse
oui
qu'en pensez vous
ce
[Musique]
le
et encore trois petites réponses
oui
aucune réponse à 99
est passé à st voilà vos réponses donc
il ya une grosse partie qui était qui et
pas mal sur le nom certes rsa s'est
réparti aux convenances % de gens qui
viendront c'est pour ça qu'ils sont de
l'autre côté
donc la verdir que la moyenne et
peut-être deux etc etc une femme à la
tête d'un ou deux on va dire 2 et du
coup bang est donc en fait migrer donc
la réponse était non aidés par l indice
dans le cadre puisqu'il ya pas mal de
gens qui on demandait s'il variable
était indépendante et j'ai pas supposer
que les variables étaient indépendantes
donc et donc qu'à général on peux pas
supposer eva rivet indépendante et en
fait quand il va ne sont pas
indépendantes dont on a pas égalité donc
la réponse était non vous avez répondu
deux ça vous fait 8,4 points bien là
c'est bien
on va démontrer tout ça n'a rien assez
simple pour laquelle on pouvait deviner
que la réponse serait non c'est que si
jamais on n'a y est égal à x ou y c'est
une copie de x6 y elle est l une est une
copie de hicks l'autre pi 2 x et y
finalement ça va être juste entropie 2 x
puisque dès qu'on connaît knicks ya plus
aucune incertitude sur y donc on ne peut
imaginer intuitivement que l'incertitude
sur sur x et y
si par exemple vous voulez avoir savoir
on va dire le sexe 2
ses deux enfants l'un d'eux est un
garçon vous avez deux enfants et vous
savez qu'ils sont des jumeaux face à des
jumeaux identiques à des jumeaux
homozygotes c'est comme ça qu'on a fait
des pas des jumeaux identiques de 6-2 si
vous avez des jumeaux identiques bas le
luxe connaître le sexe de l'or mais vous
devez vous dit tout sur le sexe de
l'autre donc l'entropie de 2 x et y 6 x
et sec du premier y de la y sexe de
l'autre cinq ans que l'entropie de xy
c'est juste une entropie 2x et donc du
coup c'est pas monozygotes certes
monozygotes ne s'est pas dupe l'entropie
de xy ici ça va être deux fois landreau
qui savaient pas deux fois l'entreprise
dx7 juste l'entropie de x donc c'est là
un exemple ou à cause de la corrélation
très fort contre x et y
elle va en fait x y et le l'entropie de
xy
c'est juste c'est pas la somme des
entreprises s'est juste trompé de x donc
on en parle on va démontrer ça donc ça
va un théorème une photo mc nous dit
qu'en fait on va te montrer un truc un
peu plus plus fort que ça n'en fait non
je veux pas démontré ça on va passer
directement un autre problème ça va un
autre théorème qui qui est un peu plus
générale du coup qui va dire que en fait
l'entreprise de x et y
c'est à l'entropie 2x plus notre copie
de y
sachant x donc intuitivement si si je
parle de reprendre l'exemple des des
jumeaux monozygotes et du coup ça veut
dire que donc notre pi sur les sexes des
deux enfants c'est entropie pour l'un
plus l'entropie de l'autre sachant que
je connais la valeur de l'an est en fait
l'autre au pire du sexe de l'autre
sachant la valeur de
entre eux ça va être zéro intuitivement
parce que les sexes demain sachant
qu'ils sont jumeaux monozygotes
détermine sexe neutre et du coup il ya
plus aucune incertitude sur l'entreprise
de l'autre sur de sextos donc bon on va
démontrer sa la démonstration n'est pas
très intéressante mais bon quand même
faire quelques démonstrations c'est
juste un calcul mais moi ça me permet de
vous habituer à manipuler un peu ses
expressions
donc on avait vu que haschke xy
c'est égal à
- la somme de surtout les x y de la
probabilité comment je vais voter je me
tais on était comme ça après l'été que x
y est égal à x y fois le log en base 2
de la probabilité que x y lit des galas
et l'idée si naturel c'est que on veut
séparer une partie sur x et une partie
sur y sache ni x alors là on s'est donc
c'est son gros formule des probabilités
conditionnelles
on sait que la probabilité que x y est
égal à x y
ça passe et ça va être la probabilité
d'abord d'avoir x est égal à x fois la
probabilité que y est égal à y
sachant que x est égal à x ça c'est la
formule des probabilités conditionnelles
une autre façon de dire c'est que
probabilités conditionnelles de y
sachant ix basse et l'ensemble des cas
où
on a x et y / l'ensemble des cars dont
la justice est égale à ixelles parmi
l'ensemble des cas on sait déjà
accueilli ces dégâts la x
partie relative des grecs et il y va
c'est ce terme 10 et par ce terme
du coup ça on peut leur entrée dans
notre dans notre expression
donc ça nous fait h2x y est égal à mort
la somme surtout les xy de la
probabilité de x est égal à x
probabilité qu'il y est égal à y voit le
log on base 2 et de la probabilité est x
est égal à x ouais la probabilité
qu'elle y était bien les y
sachant que cette égalité est là on va
utiliser une propriété du logarithme qui
est que le logarithme d'un produit son
homologue de jeu l'écrire si je fais le
log de à x b c'est le log base hommes
vont se manger n'importe quelle base de
a plus le log de bcc vraiment la
propriété fondamentale du log qui est la
raison pour laquelle le log est aussi
important ici c'est que le log permet
cette de transformer des modifications
en addition par les probabilités par
construction notamment passé par cette
c3 était conditionnel est
fondamentalement multiplicatif un
formule de bells est fondamentalement
multiplicatif et du coup si on veut
transformer ça en addition pour parler
de l'addition des informations ce qui
est une notion assez simple c'est
naturel pas il faut utiliser le sport
que ces raisons pour laquelle shannon a
introduit sologne et du coup maintenant
si on applique ça
donc on voit que h2x y alors maintenant
je vais étape par étape
donc c'est la somme sur les xy de la
probabilité pour x est égal à x
probabilité à part mirror où il ya eu
une erreur grave j'ai enfreint les lois
des probabilités
ce qu'ils voient à la place mais accuse
donc jeu a écrit ça cette fois donc on
utilise cette relation donc c'est le log
en base de la croix était de x est égal
à 6 plus le camp parce que la
probabilité que les y est égale y
sachant qu'ils existent ok donc là
peut-être allé un peu vite
il ya pas mal de détails sinon ça va
mettre ça dans un coin on va prendre ça
en fait on peut diviser la somme séparer
la sentant peut distribuer puis séparés
la somme en deux dont xi vous n'êtes pas
très à l'aise avec ça désolé mais j'ai
sauté quelques étapes
du coup on ne sait pas on doit regarder
juste certaine manière juste cette
partie là et puis après avoir gardé
votre parti de ces jeux parce que vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire mais on va
devoir regarder cette partie là donc
c'est moins la somme pour les xy de la
probabilité que x est égal à x fois la
probité de y est égale y sachant x est
égal à x de la province du logar base de
la praille txt yann alix mois
entièrement acquis qu'ils distribuent la
somme sur les x y
la probabilité que x est égal à x sur la
probabilité il récupère vivre avec sa
cheminée ghana x
le log en baisse 2 la probabilité
qu'elle y était bien ça y est ça change
et à petit à petit on commence à voir
apparaître les démons terme
si vous vous sentez venir là l'idée là
c'est que on va faire pour ce terme à ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va essayer
d'isoler un peu cette partie sur y va la
mettre un peu à l'écart et du coup la
somme ça permet de la séparer une partie
juste sur x il y apprend vadis très
juste sur les grecs
ça a fait la somme sur les x ça c'est
juste la partie qui est indépendante des
grecs finalement du blog en base 2 et
c'est égal à x et après on a juste la
partie sur y cimes sur les grecs de
qualité y est égalé grec ça chiant c'est
égal à x et de l'autre côté sont à faire
ce qu'on va faire à peu près la même
chose on va d'abord regarder vu sa
partie sur l'extérieur ça donc c'est la
somme pour les x de probabilités que x
est égal à 1 x fois la somme sur les y
profiter elle y est égal à y chanter
c'est égal à 6 log en base de l'été les
grecs étaient à y sachant que ces
gars-là x peu serré
et donc là de la remarque clé c'est que
cette quantité de là en fait c'est la
somme c'est sachant qu'à lister garric
c'est la somme de toutes les valeurs de
y déployer de tous les malheurs des
grecs qu'en finale finalement ça sonne
toutes les pneus alors possible de y
faut conditionner paris s'est dégagée x
une somme juste de probabilités de tous
les événements possibles sur y est donc
ça a été galère donc comme c'est égal à
1 il reste plus que juste ce terme là et
ce terme là bas on reconnaît finalement
l'entropie de x on sait à quoi il était
excellent x fois l'information dx est
donc ce premier terme là c'est
simplement acteur x c'est pas très beau
et de l'autre côté en fait de l'autre
côté si le fasse et que ces moyennes
surtout les cas des x le finalement la
probabilité conditionnelle de y est égal
à y de l'information de y
sachant xx et donc ça c'est simplement
l'entropie de y
sachant qu'elle x est égal à x
et donc là on a finalement la moyenne
des autres au pied conditionnelle oui
par rapport à x et d'entreprises
conditionnelle dans quelques je vais
écrire donc la moyenne des entrepôts
conditionnelle c'est finalement
l'espérance sens que je tire x au hasard
de l'entropie de y
sachant x est en fait une entropie
michel dantin l'entropie ce que je tire
x l'espérance parce que je tire x de
l'entropie de l'itraxx h en x ça c'est
par définition en fait par définition
c'est la manière dont on définit h2y
sachant x et hdx mois h y s'a chantix
voilà
il ya peut-être un truc assez assez haut
niveau de notation en fait il ya
toujours un truc un peu bizarre avec ses
notations en termes d'espérance et on
est d'être ultra pratique ces notations
là mais elle est assez étrange surtout
si on était habitué parce que parce qu
on est un peu un mélange entre variable
aléatoire des réalisations de la
barrière méritoire donc c'est quand on
n'est pas habitué je pense que c'est
important de développer le calcul pour
être sûr que les calculs marche bien
mais quand on s'y habitue un petit peu
enfin si c'est bien très pratique est en
tout cas on a démontré le théorème cdu
fdp ce qu'il fallait démontrer qu'un
grand sourire en biais yep et la banda
de notre notre démonstration et le sens
plus général c'est quand même quelque
chose assez profond c'est que l'autre
pied d'un système complexe on peut la
décomposé en plusieurs composants de ce
système mais c'est pas tout à fait la
seule salle est une somme conditionnelle
et d'une certaine manière ce terme là
l'entropie conditionnelle elle en cotte
parfaitement la notion intuitive de
corrélation qui permet de réduire
finalement l'incertitude sur un centre
du système
ah oui oui point de signer merci c'est
plus qu'il ya un an ici pourtant il
faudrait faire plus wha wha mois sa
merci un vrai site ulla t
un calcul on peut passer des parties des
choses un peu plus pourtant ça c'est
assez profonde est là mais on va passer
à l'électrique tech plus tu es pullman
boeing je sais pas des trucs un peu plus
patient puisse suivant mon nez aux 5
c'est simple cuisine numéro 5
alors le cuisine numéro 5 donc quand ça
à parler de la notion de code
parce que grosses applications de tout
ça donc c'est l'article chanal s'appelle
bath maddock mathematical fille york
communication aucune théorie
mathématique de la communication donc
c'est vraiment à voir avec qu'est-ce qui
peut être communiqué et en gros l'idée
de shannan c'est que l'entropie enfin
vint le génie grande de shannon s'est il
ya beaucoup de respect vraiment génial
si dans son article est un des génies
c'est vraiment de trouver ce lien entre
cette notion assez vague d'entropie
assez voilà c'est ça c'est cette notion
d'entropie très très abstraite et
finalement quelque chose de très concret
de très appliqué qui a à voir avec ce
qui peut être communiqué et avec
l'encodage de l'information et ça c'est
absolument critique ans et c'est
vraiment des trucs plus révolutionnaire
parce que c'est pas du tout spécifiques
à une nouvelle technologie
en fait l'article de shannon par
beaucoup de langage naturel qu'est ce
qu'on peut encoder dans des phrases en
anglais par exemple ou dans d'autres
langues qui parle du français
exemples français et et plus
généralement le morse et tout ça il ya
des connexions avec beaucoup beaucoup de
langage qui sont utilisés est vraiment
le génie de chan c'est de prendre un
truc a laissé en gage de probabilités
d'être très continue très sale
impression que ça peut il ya peu cette
idée que les choses peuvent pas s'en
codée dans des trucs discret voyez
qu'elle faisait on continue est vraiment
le tour de génie de shannon c'est de
dire et quand même avant chanel beaucoup
de genres miser sur l'analogique par
exemple pour communiquer un message
outre altantique il y avait une des
câbles sous le souffle sous l'océan
et puis on envoyait des signaux mais les
signaux envoyés en gros c'était les
ondes sonores des bisounours étaient les
ondes sonores
donc c'était un logique du ton sang sous
le signe inquiétant ont envoyé était
analogue à ce qu'on voulait communiquer
c'est à dire le son d'avoine et l'idée
vraiment génial de shannon c'est de se
dire bah finalement on peut on n'est pas
obligé de rester à nice sur le point de
vue analogique on peut on connaît tout
ça dans un truc discret façon qu'on en
code se
la boîte où ça dans des textes et qu'il
perde d'information et en ce moment ça
et on pouvait se demander jusque là est
ce que cette perte d'information était
inéluctable bien voir vraiment l'un des
plus grands génies de shannon c'est de
dire non c'est de cette perte
d'informations dans le codage discret
n'est pas inéluctable
tout signal analogique un équivalent
discret et bon voilà l'exemple par
lesquels on peut avoir ces étudiants
discret d'ailleurs celle-ci c'est un peu
lié à la fixe et c'est que le moment
échantillonne parce que enfin temps
tant qu'humain en tout cas on n'est pas
capable de mesurer des trucs de l'ordre
de la fin de semaine de 10 puissance
moins cinq seulement 15 secondes et même
les machines ne répond pas à faire ça il
en fait il ya même des raisons
théoriques de penser que comme en moins
une équation qui s'appelle e égal à
chenilles e égal avenue sadi que
l'énergie est proportionnelle à la
fréquence du coup si on part dans des
fréquences très très grande
donc si on veut communiquer si on veut
échantillon très très très précisément
en signal
on est obligé de faire plein de mesures
et on a tant donné et du coup avec la
fréquence est le nombre de mesures par
seconde et si on augmente la fréquence
on augmente aussi l'énergie donc un
signal qui a beaucoup de détails à
toutes les échelles de temps comme des
échelles très faible de temps c'est
aussi un signal qui compte me tient
énormément d'énergie et du coup il ya
une limite finalement physique
à fin août la énergétique à ce qui peut
être communiquée de manière purement
analogique et en fait on peut même
relier sa mécanique quantique et dire
que les énergies rhdp maximale dans des
unités de temps donnée qui font que
finalement une vision discrète on perd
pas grand chose mon grand-père aurillac
bref rebond à la question est ce qu'un
signal 2x d'entropie h2x peut être
encodé de sorte que la longueur de x est
toujours inférieure à un plus h2x qu'est
ce que vous pensez
et
[Musique]
la cinquième question une heure et demie
par trois heures
le
bavure pour finir je voulais finir cette
histoire de shannon on va ffi c'est un
des trucs géniaux café
shannon ces deux d'imaginer un autre
passion de communiquer à travers
l'atlantique est
l'idée c'était d'avoir grâce au signal
numérique on était capable de faire des
corrections de correction de codes
notamment l'idée c'est qu'on envoie un
signal maintenant digit et discret
digitalisées fait discret
et avec des outils de correction de code
donc le signal va être perturbée mais il
est possible de le restituer entièrement
avec juste un être très grande
probabilité et du coup au lieu d'avoir
un signal qui se perd au fur et à mesure
la communication si bien qu'il peut pas
traverser l'atlantique qui noyaient dans
dans tout le bruit causé par les erreurs
de transmission
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire pourra
dire que pour contrer sa bombe après
amplifier le signal
régulièrement le problème c'est que si
on rouvre amplifie le signale
régulièrement on amplifie le signal on
amplifie aussi le bruit du coup le
rapport bruit sur signal reste très
élevé en fait ils augmentent
continuellement et à la fin le bruit
tellement grand que le signal a disparu
bien lille et le chien c'est que au
milieu de l'atlantique
au fur et mesure plusieurs endroits de
notre antique le signal discret seraient
analysés et au gras salés système de
redondance de l'information pourrait le
résideront constitué entièrement avec
très grande probabilité et puis ensuite
continué à le transmettre au suivant et
puis et puis le suivant le restituerait
à nouveau quai retransmettra le message
correct bien si l'on suit en fait en
faisant ça ils le nuc est possible de
transmettre des informations ne fasse de
manière fiable travers l'atlantique
et
piqué du coup la question on signale un
x d'entropie h2x peut être un côté de
sorte que la longueur de code de x est
toujours inférieur à 1 puis 5 2 x y a
pas énormément de réponses 47 points ça
va si vous savez pas hésité pas à lire
tout je sais pas ça fait partie d'une
bonne réponse
un quiz bizien c'est aussi de dire je ne
sais pas pour vous ne sais pas
[Musique]
et
le live avec le passé et un manque
d'intérêt j'ai appris certains m'ont dit
que il avait avancé que feront preuve de
série avait annoncé ma venue
pahor besoin discussions entre défis
scientifiques depuis plus d'une semaine
pour faire laver gd oui mais par contre
il m'a pas confirmé la date est donc
vrai que j'ai envie c'est un oui mais ça
je ne sais pas edit ah c'est un peu un
coup à redoubler les gens disent ça tue
pas ses primes mais jamais de répondre
oui je veux bien mais quand
e
59 réponse instant
mais
[Musique]
samedi ça m'arrangerait ben oui
j'adore ces instructions a promis
comme pour le bruit de fond
de pierre coulisses
65 réponse pour l'instant
wes à 50% techniquement c'est différent
d'eux ne sais pas c'est mais c'est la
réponse avec un maximum d'entropie est
ce que j'ai oublié de expliqué tout à
l'heure je reviendrai donc très bientôt
mais l'entropie maximale c'est qu'on
dirait une probabilité entre 0 bien
comme ça c'est un scoop wright et égalé
au milieu égal à 1 devenue une autre qui
à ce moment-là qu'est gala donc la
réponse le jeu mis au milieu c'est la
réponse d'incertitude maximale braz et
est valide
e
80 de réponses on se rapproche des 100
tête attendait 100
oui donc pour rappel donc le quiz si
vous répondez zéro c'est à dire que vous
êtes sûr que la réponse est non si vous
répondez 10 et turcs la réponse oui et
si vous mettez 5 c'est que d'être un
état d'incertitude maximale mais t3
s'est donc penché pour le nom qu'ils ont
été 9 c'est que vous êtes
assez confiant ya encore un petit doute
a atteint les 100 réponses parfaites ok
ça donne ça la courbe donc aucun signal
entre x d'entropie h2x fallait d'encoder
de sorte que la longueur de codes du
code de x est toujours inférieure à un
plus h2x vous êtes beaucoup à répondre
oui avec beaucoup de confiance et la
moyenne j'ai envie de dire qu'elle est à
peu près à l'oeuf ou 8 15 41 % quand
même c'est à dire pas mal j'ai envie de
dire la moyenne est à 9 pro c'était bien
donc
donc si je regarde des scores moyens
méthodes 9 et malheureusement à défoncer
non on va au conflent donc il ya
plusieurs raisons pour laquelle la
réponse pourrait être non une d'entre
elles cessé c'est notre pire est une
mesure pas si discrète que ça mais une
réponse un peu plus fondamental c'est
que c'est possible d'avoir une moyenne
d'âge moyen
la longueur moyenne du code qui est
inférieur à 1 puis 5 2 x mais il peut y
avoir des cas où
sans collage sera beaucoup correspondre
à des codes beaucoup beaucoup un très
très grand ça arrivera typiquement si la
distribution des messages et pas du tout
uniforme c'est des messages qui sont
beaucoup beaucoup plus probable que
d'autres
ben non c'est casser ces modes message
beaucoup plus pour probable ben
intuitivement il devra être encodé par
des par une suite de symboles très très
court par très peu de symbole donc
typiquement l'arrivée des trains le mot
oui dans toutes les langues fait
rarement plus de quatre lettres je
m'aligne de casser ce sont des mots
d'une salade au très court alors que des
mots beaucoup plus compliqué comme
anticonstitutionnellement qui sont aussi
moins comme un ben naturellement elle va
t'en connais avec beaucoup plus de deux
lettres dans un langage encodage
d'optimal soit on va faire ça et c'est
la raison pour laquelle lorsque
l'entropie lorsque le signal est pas du
tout uniforme
en moyenne on peut avoir quelque chose
de très proche de l'entropie mais on va
avoir sur des pires cas qui sont bien
plus grands que l'entropie que le codage
moyens et donc que l'entropie donc la
réponse était non donc là ça fait un peu
mal pas mal de l'écrire ça c'est moins
quatre précédents le positif mais ça
fait pas là alors on va démontrer le
théorème plus
en gros l'entropie channon est quand
même la borne moyenne
essentiellement la borne moyenne une
entropie deux chaînes avaient quand même
pas loin en gros de l'encodage optimale
mais essentiellement l'encodage optimale
et pour le démontrer
voyez il faudra démontrer que il existe
un an un encodage capable de faire par
exemple un plus h2x je veux pas faire ça
aujourd'hui ce qu'on va juste démontrer
c'est que ce que séguéla ont montré même
pas si c'est vrai pas si c'est parce que
le côté discret toujours un peu chiant
mais casillas si on prend des six de
suite de signes de signaux qu'est ce que
le littoral de shannon c'est que si on
veut on a un flux continu comme ca de 2
les messages dont qu'il s'arrête jamais
les messages et thouars deschênes s'est
dit que il vise un encodage qui est
capable de faire une collecte plus des
pilotes sur la moyenne de dons qu'on
voit c'est à dire que pour des signaux
qui ont été très faible probabilité
puisque comprend des messages très très
longue plus profiter de chaque message
est très faible
verson garder des proies et et qui sont
toutes très faible eh bien il existe des
encodages qui sont gros hdx lucet
peut-il en moyenne le pire cas c'est
peut être pire ok mais nous on va pas
démontré ça on va regarder ce qu'on a
démontré c'est on va montrer que non je
vais pas écrire comme ça ce qu'on va
montrer c'est que le longueur moyenne
l'espérance la longueur du code
donc je mets des bars pour dire longueur
du code
on sait qu'on peut encoder des messages
donc l'espérance de la longueur du
message
on va il va se poser un code binaire
doute le code ça est une suite de 0,1
l'espérance de la longueur du code ce
qu'on va montrer c'est que ça c'est
forcément plus grand que h2x on pourra
pas faire mieux que l'entropie de
shannon l'entropie de shannon est une
borne fondamental de ceux de la
compression alors bizarrement j'ai pas
trouvé de preuves de sa dent
dans les livres
puis j'ai regardé du coup je proposais
ma démonstration c'est possible nos
stations plus simple car elle est donc
la raison pour laquelle on a sali la
démonstration que je vous propose c'est
d'imaginer que en fait un code surtout
binaire enfin papa cabinet un code c'est
vraiment une sorte de succession de
tests si on en code x avec une chute de
0 et 2 hors le premier big donc le
première lettre
qu'est ce qu'il ya là 01 forcément plus
plus grand ou plus grand idéal supérieur
ou égal qu'il ya des cas où il ya
égalité des caresses et review du
programme qualité donc la première
lettre ça peut être zéro ou un beau
cadeau qu'un possible
puis la deuxième lettre a peut être
aussi 0 ou 1
et puis mon titre est possible qu'on
s'arrête ici par dont 10 00 c'est le
l'encodage du conte s'arrête ici c'est
plus et qu'on continue
à chaque fois 0 1
et donc si on en arrive donc ici j'ai
plusieurs issues possibles donc là ça
serait un message 00 l'âge et le message
010 j'ai le message 011
là j'ai un 0 0 l'ag 1,01 et la gêne est
une façon de penser de réfléchir à ce
problème c'est que ça c'est un message
xbox et un message x qui a été encodée
par exemple par 0-0 et la manière s'il
en connaît c'est un peu comme si vous
posez un premier test
la première lettre c'est un test et là
il m'a sorti 0 et du coup j'ai pris
cette branche et ensuite j'ai fait un
deuxième test il m'a dit 0 et à partir
ses deux aces de gestes j'ai
complètement réduit mon incertitudes sur
la valeur de x et je sais que ce x
correspond à ce que la valeur qui s'est
un peu d'ail 0-0 et l'idée de la preuve
que je propose c'est vraiment d'étudier
le nombre de tests qui sera nécessaire
pour identifier
alors pour démontrer sa or la première
remarque donc un bon code déjà mon code
donc il ya dans le code est bon on va
dire aux fidèles ou me dire je pense
hisse en finale
oui je veux dire final six pages par
l'état et en technique
si il est donc le terme technique la
pensée un effectif objectif c'est à dire
quoi ça veut dire que si on a deux
messages différence une laïque ce
différend de y
deux messages différents alors je veux
que le code de x soit égal au pod de y a
du sens si si si deux messages
différents avaient le même code
alors forcément je perdrais de
l'information on ne regardant que le
code puisque je ne saurais pas à quel
message
ça correspond donc donc la csmf est
binaire et est ce que j'ai appelé fidèle
aux projectiles alors pourquoi est-ce
que sa salle est intéressant c'est à
dire que si je regarde non je vais
partir de l'entropie 2x hdx ça ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est la même chose
que l'entropie du code de x pourquoi
parce que à cause de cette propriété
d'injecter vite et si je connais à bord
de l'iss jeu quand même code il suffit
de calcul code l inverse si je connais
le coach je connais x puisque le code et
munich
donc il ya l'entropie 2x est égal
l'entreprise du code dx ok maintenant je
vais appeler chacun des points ça je
vais appeler ça le test c'est un puits
en train d'un test ces deux pays un test
ces trois pouces et 2 peut dépendre
d'océan mais ordonnée dans ce sens et
l'entropie du code de x du coup ça va
être notre opi de chacune des lettres
qui composent une de ces deux ces trois
et ainsi de suite
peut on se pose on que le plus long
codage et de longueur elle par exemple
c'est l'entropie de l'ensemble de sa ou
potentiellement cni même pas défini il
faudrait que vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
et là je vais appliquer la formule qu'on
a vue précédant un os ouvert on avait vu
antoine qu'on avait vus c'était que h2x
y est égal à acheter x + h2y ça change
je vais appliquer ce théorème ici vous
savez fait h2c en plus h2c 2 sa chance
est un plus hb que ces trois sa chance
et c1 et c2 plus et ainsi de suite
jusqu'à plus htc m sachant c1 c2 jusqu'à
cn - ok
et en fait on aura de l'entreprise sur
ses deux uniquement si on a vraiment une
lettre ces deux du coup ça ça ne peut
arriver que si c'est cette entropie à
sera strictement positive seulement si
on a effectivement 1 c2 à tester du coup
c'est pas très beau ce que je vais
écrire mais là l'hiver utilement c'est
que la halte c'est un plus la
probabilité parce que donc ça ne sera le
cas que si le code de x la longueur du
code de x et au mans il ya là deux fois
du coup à l'entropie déteste qu'on aura
à fait à ce moment là du coup je vais
appeler c'est à ces deux sachant ses 1
et cat 2 x super aygalades et ensuite tu
comme ça pour éviter que le cadre de x
ça supérieur égale à trois voix le hcr
citation il à l'observation clé notre
observation clé c'est que chacune de ces
entreprises ici correspond à une
variable binaire qui sera égal à zéro ou
un c soit sa part 0 soir une chacune de
ces entreprises cédées entropie de deux
variables billère et ça c'est forcément
inférieur et gala
alors pourquoi vous avez vu la dernière
fois
beaucoup d'autres militent et pas la
dernière fois on avait vu la dernière
fois que on peut définir l'entropie ii
x2 père venir donc l'entropie doc est
donc cp fois le log en base 2 - paix le
log en base de de paix - un moment paix
log combas deux hommes ont p et ça ça
ressemble à ça donc ça c'est l'autre
pied en fonction de la probabilité d'une
variable binaire 0,1 et cette entropie
là on voit qu'il est forcément
inférieure à un an et atteint son
maximum en 0,5
on peut le démontrer des hommes ça évite
ainsi de prendre cette expression par
exemple à la dérive et voir ce qui se
passe donc par conséquent ici chacun de
ces termes va être inférieur ou égal à 1
et du coup ça ça est intérieure a fait
même la première lettre bon ça ce sera
la probabilité que le code soit au moins
supérieure et yann on a commencé un
donné défini que si le code une longueur
au moins égale 1 à 1
on connait un truc avec un pote qui n'a
aucune longueur il faut essentiellement
qu'il n'y ait aucune incertitude a
priori et qui est un peu d'incertitude
va fort une lettre au moins quatre on va
rajouter ça ici plus ensuite la pro a
été d'après avait pas eu de travail et
pas écrite à son travail mais il ya
moyen de la forme
c'est très rigolo ce premier
en tout cas on obtient cette inégalité
a bientôt fini cas plus il reste plus
que du calcul en fait les gros titres
astuces sont déjà des oeuvres déjà donc
donc du coup ça je peux l'écrire c'est
la sones la probabilité que le code de x
à nu longueur ou bourgi surtout l'egypte
jusqu'à lundi
simplement pour aller jusqu'au bout
jusqu'à un film et ça en fait on peut
leur écrire la même vocation de faire ça
[Musique]
il s est que en formant un petit vent en
tout cas ce qui va se passer
une belle façon d'écrire j'arrive pas la
retrouver c'est que si le code étayé et
de longueur 1
il va être nous qu'est une fois ci le
code et de longueur 2 il va être
comptées deux fois ci le code et de
longueur 3 il aurait coûté trois fois
donc en fait le code de longueur x qui
va être content et aussi autant de fois
dans cette addition que la longueur du
câble et du coup ça ça va être égal en
fait à la somme surtout les girondins
comptent jusqu'à l'infini de
probabilités que deux gifles probabilité
que le code de x soit exactement deux
longueurs j ai en fait écrire ça c'est
exactement la définition de l'espérance
de la longueur du code
une façon de montrer ça c'est de dire
que web en tout cas on arrache 2x qui
est intérieure égal à ceux à l'espéranza
longueur du code c'est bien le théorème
qu'il fallait démontrer donc cqfd
cette fois elle est intéressante
déjà parce que le résultat est
intéressant une autre raison pour
laquelle cette preuve est intéressante
parce que c'est qu'elle nous dit quand
est ce qu'on peut avoir égalité
en fait tout se passait ici seuls
l'égalité en fait elle a vraiment lieu
ici et cette inégalité elle a lieu parce
que non même pas ici en fait la vraie
inégalité c'est dans les vieux ici et
ses inégalités
elles ont elles ont lieu parce qu'on à
l'entropie qui est inférieur ou égal à 1
et en fait on va très proche de
l'égalité quand ces entreprises seront
égales un très proche de 1
et pour que ces entreprises soient
égales à 1
il faut que si je prends mon arbre de
décision ici il faut que la probabilité
de monter en haut ou en bas soit égale à
1 de lui parce que c'est là que en fait
chaque lettre va être un maximum
d'entreprises un maximum d'informations
l'information est l'incertitude c'est de
co2 il d'entropie ces deux côtés d'une
même pièce signale qu'il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes quant on l'a appris on a
gagné beaucoup d'informations donc là
avec cette preuve on voit bien que le le
maximum
le codage en optimale de la façon de se
rapprocher de l'entropie 2x c'est quand
à chaque pas chaque des chèques nouvelle
lettre en fait on est maximale mans
surpris voilà la priorité de la nouvelle
lettre est égal à 1,2 me on s'attend à
être maximum en surpoids l'espérance de
la surprise et est maximale
que
e donc ça c'est fin c'est vraiment un
truc à un problème fondamental c'est que
enfin c'est cette notion d'entropie ces
notions qui est basé sur des
probabilités des différents messages qui
dépendent du contexte comme on l'a vu
donc si on est bayésiens en fait c'est
ces probabilités correspond à notre
description de notre immense et la
manière optimale d'encoder l'information
dépend de notre ignorance et c'est une
façon de combler notre ignorance et plus
notre ignorance et est grande plus notre
entreprise initiale et est grande plus
il va falloir des codes long des
explications longues pour réduire cette
entreprise et en plus de ça ce que ça
montre c'est que les messages aux petits
mordus cas d'un point de vue purement
théorique d'informations donc si on
oublie qu'on a tous les biais cognitif
n'aurait pas réfléchir si on était tous
bayésiens la meilleure façon d'apprendre
c'est d'être constamment à moitié
surpris par chaque bit d'information
donc une conséquence de tout ça c'est
que si vous voulez apprendre beaucoup
faut être souvent beaucoup surpris si on
parle si vous lisez des textes qui font
mille caractères donc un caractère
disons c'est c'est déjà donc plusieurs
bits d'information après les
compressions la longue mais on imagine
que chacun à kara un bit d'information
dire que l'encodage optimale pour en
lisant 1000 caractères vous ferait
gagner 1000 bits d'information
mais ça c'est l'encodage optimale qui
correspond à si vous êtes surpris et
pour être sur pied par un texte maxime
allemand il faut que la probabilité de
ce texte soit un sur deux puissances
1000 ce qui est ce qui est très très
faible
vous devriez être très très surpris si
vous voulez apprendre il faut être
souvent très surpris enfin c'est quelque
chose assez profond 6-2 réfléchissez il
faut chercher la surprise pour pouvoir
apprendre beaucoup
et si vous consommez des contenus et que
ces contenus ne vous surprennent pas
finalement c'est peut-être que vous êtes
habitué à de ne plus à quoi on peut
envisager un peu profondes et tout ça en
fait un de ces nombreux trucs qui m'a
complètement man l'homme comme quand
j'ai commencé à comprendre un peu plus
ces histoires de théories d'information
hockey qu'on va passer cette longue
démonstration on va passer
au 6e cuisent ça a duré trois heures
le cul 6/6 cuisent
alors le 6ème cuisent c'est quelque
chose de nécessaire a vraiment plus un
truc de bâton à dire
et la question suivante est ce que si on
prend une variable aléatoire x parce que
l'espérance de l'ex potentiel est
supérieur à l'expo l'ancien de
l'espérance
parce qu on a l'espérance exponentielle
du mix supérieur à l'expo l'ancien de
l'espérance px typiquement assise et une
variable pas par exemple
donc c'est les applications par exemple
imaginer ensemble des séismes et les
séismes souvent mesuré sur les chiffres
des shales de de richter c'est sur le
live qu'en pensez pas ça se voit mais
celle de yves terroristes pour ça et
celle de rift heures donc l'échelle de
richter
celle de richard est une échelle
logarithmique c'est dire que si on prend
si on veut quelques plus la vraie force
de 2 d'un séisme d'amplitude du cisme
pour les techniques en fait il faudrait
il prendre l'exponentielle d'une de
l'échelle de richter et du coup si on
veut vraiment calculé
la puissance moyenne des séismes il
faudra faire l'expérience de l'ex
potentiel de l'échelle de richter
quelques défilés sur l'expérience iphone
pour chaque séisme faux calculs faudra
calculer 10 puissance et 10 puissance
l'échelle de richter pour savoir quelle
est sa force et après on fait la moyenne
surtout ça elle question c'est s'ils ont
fait ça de cette opération est ce qu'on
aura un nombre plus grand que si on fait
une autre approche qui consiste à
prendre la moyenne sur l'échelle de
richter de tous les ismes ça ça serait
l'échelle de richter moyenne et si on
prend ça fait 10 puissance à s'y
méprendre exponentielle de l'échelle de
richter
en moyenne le moyen de l'échelle de
est-ce qu'on va obtenir un autre plus
grand ou plus petit que si offert
la force moyenne une telle que la
puissance moyenne
des décisions parce que la puissance
moyenne des séismes est plus grande que
10 puissance l'échelle de richter
moyenne des séismes
alors pour répondre à la question de la
musique de fond ça s'appelle énigmatique
de
[Musique]
e
de ben saad
sans d'énigmatiques
alors ma petite pose aussi
[Musique]
je vis maintenant connaître micro
merci wen qui avait fait une remarque
sur clip born techniquement là je fais
de mon mieux pour essayer de limiter
m'approcher d'une limitation à deux des
snacks cmec est juste de notre fort
sinon il ya encore seulement 30 réponse
fichiers un petit peu mais trop
d'ignorance sur sur les réponses vous
pouvez suivre le lien ce qui serait
nouveau ici et il faut répondre entre
sur une échelle de 0 à 10 10 et c est
sûr que la réponse est oui
07/08 sur la réponse est non et au
milieu 5 c'est que vous êtes dans un
état d'entropie maximale
il ya beaucoup moins de réponse à la
crise est passé j'en prends ça se
fatiguer josé pas répond je vais prendre
un
ok ben peu de réponses dans cette fois
que pensez vous
quelqu'un dans le chat qui doit aussi
aux deux péritel ça reste une bonne
école juste que ça reste une bonne école
c'est que c'est le meilleur écoles au
monde
plusieurs jours ces travaux d'école se
retrouvent informatique c'est
top européen et mondial
ça va être intéressant d'ailleurs cela
se passe est intéressant n'est pas si
intéressant seulement mai
avec la situation du colis delà ça est
très compliqué pour les us parce que
vraiment mal pour les yeux peut-être que
universités américaines savaient
vraiment rendant difficile tout cas le
recrutement c'est ça
recherche dépend beaucoup d'étrangers de
doctorants et oublie 3g faire venir des
étrangers alors de aux états unis les
étrangers sont intéressés par les états
unis du coup on s'attend à ce qu'il y
ait plus de monde m'a transmis sa
rentrée prochaine
non là c'est pas se passer
ok bon devrait qu'on se rende pas
exponentielle mort du coup je propose
qu'on allait voir les réponses pepsi il
ya peu de réponses donc voilà vos
réponses
39 réponse c'est assez répartie comme
toi y'a pas mal de réponses extrêmes la
moyenne l'impression que ça serait
quelque chose comme 4 de moyenne veut
dire que vous avez répondu quatre donc
répondu quatre ça veut dire que derrière
il ya les 4 c'est à dire que si la
réponse était oui vous perdez ou moins
4,4 points et ses réponses et n'ont
gagné 3,6 points et la réponse
la réponse c'est oui
réponse était oui du coup vous perdez
4,4 points
il ya il restait deux reposent ici mais
c'est dommage
alors pourquoi alors qu'est ce qui se
passe en fait donc pour comprendre ça en
fait on va regarder un graphe on va
tracer le graphe de la courbe
exponentielle donc la courbe
exponentielle
on s'était pas retracé à coire
exponentielle dans un logis si sûr
desnos donc la courbe exponentielle donc
si je regarde exponentielle de x
résoudre un petit peu même pas ça c'est
quelque chose qui ressemble à ça voilà
ce qu'on voit c'est que la courbe
tourner un peu comme ça vers le haut si
vous imaginez c'est une voiture au parti
de la gauche vous tourner auriez vers la
gauche c'est faire vers le haut et non
ferreux retracer la courbe est ce qui se
passe c'est que imaginer imaginez une
distribution où il ya deux points que ce
soit sur la sa pro 7 c'est une pure
qu'elle tourne bien vers la gauche
ouais
imaginons qu'en photo vieillie et ses
deux points et soit x est égal à -11 1
soit égale à 5
donc les espérances de l'exposant ciel
x7 la moyenne des exponentielle en
espérant cesser la moyenne donc les
spurs des exponentielle donc ça c'est
exponentiel
ces puissances morin c'est la hauteur ça
c'est peu puissant 5 et donc la moyenne
entre puissants 5 et au financement 1,7
la moyenne des auteurs si je regarde ça
j'imagine qu'ils profitaient 1/2 des
deux côtés alors ça c'est le nombre au
milieu donc ça c'est vraiment la moyenne
des exponentielle on a pris les deux
valeurs exponentielle et on prend la
hauteur moyenne correspond à ce qu'on a
alors que
gris alors que la moyenne entre -1 et 5
me ce qu'elle faisait au milieu ça devra
être 2 à 2 2 c'est la moyenne et du coup
au carré ici c'est l'expérience yale de
la moyenne
et du coût exponentiel
de l'espérance classé exponentielle de
la moyenne
ce qu'on voit c'est que parce que la
courbe tourner vers la gauche vers le
haut
la moyenne d exponentielle et au dessus
de l'expérience yale de la moyenne
en fait ça s'est pointé au rêve appelle
le théorème de genzyme
vérifiez l'orthographe sont assurés un
petit doute
yoann de djendjen bailly dit que
l'expérience de exponentielle de x
supérieur égal à l'ex l'ancien de
l'espérance dx ya exponentielle tourner
vers le haut
le mot technique c'est complexe et en
fait quand james n est plus général que
ça nous réécrire complètement du
haut-rhône de james n
c'est si f et convexes alors l'espérance
ftx supérieur af de l'espérance dx
et de façon analogue et on dira si j'ai
maintenant est une fonction concave donc
une fonction concave c'est-à-dire
qu'elle tourne vers le bas par la droite
une gauche à droite à ce moment là on à
l'inégalité inverse
l'espérance de rdx inférieur à f de
l'espérance
pour être honnête je m'emmêle toujours
les pinceaux entre les deux la façon
dont on joue j'essaie de me souvenir
c'est lundi que l'espérance de x car et
c'est quelque chose qui est forcément
acquis sas est supérieur à l'espérance
de x au carré voix parce que l'espérance
de x dont karim on peut avoir des
discussions à moyenne nul
sap est égal à zéro alors que la
dissolution n'est pas égal à zéro
partout et du coup ça ça serait positif
et du coup alors la fonction mix carré
et convexes parabole c'est vers le haut
quand c'est complexe on a un supérieur
égal de grâce ce sens
voilà alors pourquoi est-ce que je vous
parle de ça c'est parce que il ya un cas
d'application très intéressant de ce
théorème de ses théorèmes avec la notion
de quelques divergences défini
définition ok donc on définit laquelle
divergences qu'elle s'est l'éclair leurs
bons coups de bach et les douleurs donc
laquelle divergences entre on va dire de
probabilités et écu de deux façons de
mesurer probabilité différentes et sur
la variable aléatoire x laquelle
divergences entre les deux donc c'est
défini
je m'entraîne définition j'ai défini
comme l'espérance lorsque je tire x de
la distribution p2 - le log la
probabilité qu au q2 x y lisait
probabilité x et sinologue en place tout
comme parfois les prix par base 2 dans
le cas de la théorie d'information de
tout mettre en place des arts pourquoi
est ce que cette définition elle est
intéressante alors décrit comme ça ça
fait pas assez bizarre bah on reconnaît
un peu donc klx pq2 quoi on rappelle que
le log ne fait que pas log de x /
exigée par y
c'est égal à loeb 2x moins nobles de y
ok je disais ça du coup c'est aussi
l'espérance lorsque je tique kyrix
aléatoirement
2 - log q2 x est donc là donc un mois
qui va apparaître que sept mois
l'espérance parce que je dis à x
selon p 2 - log de pbx accompli q c'est
que c'est une autre distribution de que
c'est une autre loi de qualité donc une
façon de penser ça c'est par exemple
c'est moi j'ai mon incertitudes et que
ces incertitudes de quelqu'un d'autre /
/ / x1 sur les données et laquelle
divergences à mesurer à quel point est
la croyance de l'eau très différente de
la mienne est donc la meilleure forme ce
calcul et c'est ça et écrit comme ça
c'est assez intéressant parce que ici on
reconnaît l'entropie ch 2 x pour
l'incertitude paix sur la variable x
alors que ça ça va être finalement la
moyenne de la quantité d'informations 2x
mesurée par q donc c'est sur un air
c'est l'espérance dans ce que je dis et
xmpp et que l'information de x mais pour
quelqu'un qui aurait fait d'incertitudes
cul qui penseraient différemment les
incertitudes et laquelle divers lens
c'est ça or on a vu qu'il ya un lien
très profond entre leur formation aux
travailleurs dont l'information est
codée et comment là
longueur du code et l'entropie en fait
ça ça voudra dire en face à sa
croissance d'une certaine manière à
l'espérance de x ce que tu as sur
ericsson d'un code optimale selon qu la
longueur d'un quad au petit manson qu
mois
l'espérance selon parce que j'étais à x
groupe et de la longueur du code
optimale et pour quelqu'un qui a une
priorité pcx l'allier c'est qu'on en
utilise un rare un code qui est optimal
selon l'incertitude qu alors que la
justice d'un coq qui optimale selon la
probité p clairement ça ça va être plus
petit pourquoi parce que c'est
accroissement au code optimale selon p
parce que x étirées selon la certitude p
alors que l'as dû servir j'ai utilisé un
encodage qui n'est pas optimale puisque
gg teaser d'un coup un codage si
l'incertitude était qu alors que la
bonne en certitude une certaine hier
c'était pcc la différence ici entre pays
qu fait que 6 à un encodage sous
optimale
alors ça c'est un peu d'âge primaire
donc au moins tu tilman ici on peut se
dire que sa mesure bien la différence
entre eux qu était parce que si tu es
paix étaient les mêmes le code optimale
sera la même dans les deux cas mais là
me le quad optimale peu différent parce
que tu avais croyez des choses
différentes et à ce moment là le code de
cul et sous-optimale du coup la longueur
des codes de qu en moyenne seront plus
longs tu pour les codes de paix du coup
alex et xsara envie de dire que cette
divergence ce sera forcément super leur
égal à zéro en fait on peut le prouver
pour obtenir surtout c'est qu elles
divergent ce qu'elle est une mesure de
différences entre les deux incertitudes
qu ep est donc un théorème important
c'est de dire que cas elle est super
égal à zéro dans ce cas elle est
toujours supérieure à 4,0 quel que soit
et donc je vais démontrer sa
démonstration n'est pas très compliqué
la démonstration
elle repose sur le fait que la fonction
qui a
regard za la fonction qui a à z associe
- log deux aides ont pas ce cette
fonction là elle est complexe
alors on peut le vérifier juste entre à
son biographe
on peut aussi démontré en prenant la
dérive et mais on va se contenter de
dessiner un graphe
aujourd'hui si on écrit - loeb en base
de dx ça me fait une fonction l'acquis
qui tourne bien vers le haut si vous
vous imaginez vous allez vers le bas et
vous tourner vers le haut vers la gauche
ou droit de tourner vers la gauche et ça
c'est une fonction qui est complexe et
du coup comme avec convexe on peut
appliquer par jensen par le théorème de
shenzhen
on sait que l'espérance n'est pas ce que
je dis à tiques sont surmontées mois log
q26 divisé pdx ça je sais que ce sera
supérieur égal c'est complexe est
supérieu rial a moins la gambas 2 de
l'espérance parce que je tiens x ça
chantait de q2 x / pbx
alors ça c'est aussi - la gambas 2 alors
je peux développer ça donc les séances
ça veut dire que je prends la somme sur
toutes les valeurs de x2 ce que de
l'intérieur de de l'espérance de cuda
x10 est parti les x fois la probabilité
de x donc là on a les pbx qui s'annulent
du coup ça me fais moi log en base de la
somme sur et x6d x ore la somme des
culées x est la somme de toutes les
probabilités sur toutes les barres de x
ça assez égal à 1
du coup ça c'est égal à moi log en
baisse de 2,1 et moins longues en base
de 2 ha bah ça fait zéro ces deux
puissances combien est égal à un droit
d'option 0 ça fait gala et du coup comme
ça ça c'était aussi égal à kehl
on a bien montré que cas elle est
supérieure à gan à 0 cqfd qu'elle est
bien une mesure de distancer une façon
de comparer c'est quand j'oublie que
l'ordre est de passer à l'écran nous
avons vu la qualité de vie très du coup
la démonstration par sur cette fonction
qui est complexe et implique le théorème
de johnson à la fonction - la gambas 2
du coup ça donne ça et ensuite quand on
développe sa référence passe une somme
surtout les x de la quantité à
l'intérieur fois la probabilité de x
quand elle était lectrice annuler
n'obtiendra - la gambas de la somme des
cuvées xl5 et cuda ixon sur tous les
éléments de
de la probité selon qu dx
c'est égal à 1 et du coup ça fait moins
à log en baisse de 2,1 et de prince est
égal à zéro
ces puits était cool du coup on voit
bien que la klc laquelle divergences
c'est bien une mesure deux espèces de
distance mot distance un peu technique
en en mathématiques c'est une espèce de
mesures de différences entre pays qu est
qu en ségala 0 ccpp enrouée ces gars là
q mais les qui sont un peu différents
laquelle divergences de vue strictement
positive ok on va passer cuisent 7
donc le plus est celle qui dit que en
ajoutant qu' on avait x et y
voilà plusieurs modèles pour x y
maintenant si on suppose qu'ils sont
indépendants
alors forcément l'entropie conjointe h2x
ivac augmente mécaniquement elle aussi
on sait que c'est
vrai ce que c'est peu quel est votre
intuition de saison thropy de cette eau
et d'information
mais bon
[Musique]
le
l'arc est votre impression
le fait que x et y soient indépendants
augmente
l'entropie de xy nécessairement
oui
[Musique]
commençait à fatiguer ya moins de
réponses très
avec elle contient d'arrivée
donc il ya pis pour ceux qui viennent
d'arriver
la question actuelle c'est ajoute
l'hypothèse d'indépendance entre xy
n'augmente l'entreprise conjointe contre
x et y paraît l'entropie convaincu allez
y donc d'incertitude sur aix y engage
régulariser
donc pour répondre vous allez sur ce
lien dit que vous pensez vous pouvez
décrire l'étendue de notre ignorance on
copie maximale à 5 vous pouvez toujours
debout 06 lui est sûr que s'ils n'ont
dit si vous êtes sûr que ces 8
participer ainsi à
[Musique]
mon avis collectif
et je dois bien dire que pour l'instant
la vie collectifs
bon voila il a une certaine note qui est
pas très nettement au-dessus de 0 0
c'est celui qui répond tout le temps je
ne sais pas du tout les premiers
maximale alors chroniqueur voudrait que
j'envoie le lien dans le tchat
en fait c'est un peu compliqué
techniquement parce que je suis sur deux
ordinateurs et donc si d'autres
personnes peuvent le faire ma place et
ça va c'est quand même pas dire non plus
trop long à écrire j'imagine
écrivez
et sinon dans le dans la description de
la vidéo il ya un lien vers la première
questions du quiz et je vous suis
remplacé qu également qu en parle plus
est cette question
et
une remarque sur le bruit de mon pc
ça chauffe
je pense quoi obs pour énormément de
nous sommes énormément de ses pubs
oui
ok
bon on atteint les 30 réponse
peu sont contentés une
oui
alors donc vos réponses
concert assez assez largement pour le
oui donc la moyenne je pense que huit
pas bien quoi moyenne ouï-dire 8
ok donc vous avez répondu oui tu ce donc
r il ya 8 ça nous fait - 15 26 points si
vous êtes 31,4 et ils se procurent la
bonne réponse était oui du coup marquer
8 juin 2004 plus 8,4 ya ça fait plaisir
oui donc qu'on augmente en effet qu'on
augmente l'incertitude
quand on augmente l'indépendance on
augmente aussi incertitudes en raison et
une raison très intuitive sais que si je
reprends l'histoire de deux jumeaux
monozygotes c'est un cas où il ya très
peu de dépendants très peu
d'indépendance est très dépendant on est
vu que l'entropie ont fait était hdx
comme un seul des deux est enfin faite
on a aussi vu l'équation on avait aussi
vu l'équation m'avait aussi vu
l'équation h2x y est égal à h2x plus h2y
sachant x et h2y sachons x en fait il va
être maximal quand on peut rien dire sur
y sachant x et du coup quand x y sont
indépendants donc je pensais que la
réponse est oui
et en fait l'une des grandes idées
d'acteurs et les pharmaciens qui est
intéressant c'est cette notion
d'information mutuelle donc qui va
essayer de quantifier à quel point x et
y sont liés st pauli les sacs à pain une
information mutuelle entre x y
donc on part donc informations mutuel
c'est l'expression et de l'information
mutuelle entre x et y
i 2 x y elle est définie comme qu'elle
divergences entre la vraie probabilité
probabilité jeunes aimeraient profiter
laquelle vivent sur xy sur les variables
xy de la vraie probabilité
versus d'ailleurs à kelly berlin selon
la note comme ça je sais pas pourquoi
mais comme ça n'est pas une virgule on
met deux barges vers suspect de x on
croit p2 y est ce que l'on entend par là
c'est ça c'est c'est en gros on prend le
mode lp on suppose que x y sont
indépendants formellement c'est à dire
que la probabilité ou si je prends cette
priorité xy que xy vanille c'est y ça ça
va être égal à donc si son indépendance
et le produit pdx fois heist op den y
est ça en général c'est différent de la
probabilité mais sur le risque y est
chirac pasqua ici y s'ils sont
dépendantes en général ils se sont fait
pas d'hypothèse on peut pas dire que ça
c'est égal au produit
pis le vix fois frappé d y passer six
ans qu à laquelle divergences dans
l'information mutuelle regarde la
différence entre le modèle ou bon on
mais des croyants sur x y ou louer le
modèle où on prend ces croyances monras
vous qui votez indépendance et
intuitivement si il sait gré action
indépendant si selon la praille tpx y
sont déjà indépendant alors enfin ces
deux modèles sur les mêmes puisque dans
ce mode lp on suppose qu'ils sont déjà
indépendants et du coup l'information
mutuelle sera égal à zéro donc pour
mixer y soient indépendants selon tes
sur la probité paix alors l'information
mutuelle est égal à zéro donc écrire ça
comme théorème donc si x et y sont
indépendants ou parfois si noté avec un
signal est un symbole orthogonale ça
c'est indépendant alors il lui qui y est
égal à zéro
démonstration c'est que la calèche
qu'elle divergence est égal à zéro
si on a la même probabilité à gauche ni
à droite
et lorsqu'ils sont indépendants bas et
la même quoique à gauche aucun doute que
c'est clair mais à l inverse quand x et
y sont très très lié à laquelle
divergences enfin le modèle ici va être
très différent de ce modèle
d'indépendance et du coup l'information
mutuel va montrer à quel point il sait y
ne sont pas indépendants quel point on
peut en savoir sur y juste en
connaissant x par exemple
donc voilà et donc on peut bomber jeu
mais quelques théorème je vais pas les
démontrer on peut aussi le fait que donc
d'information mutuelle entre lycées y
c'est l'autre opi 2x plus entropie de y
moi mon thropy conjointe entre x livre
activement 6 x et y sont très
indépendants
donc s'il sait que ces grecs sont très
indépendants alors hdx y ce sera très
proche d'eux
à 6-6 et y soit centrale très dépendants
de luxe y ce sera les expulsions y
sécurité l'information de mutuelle donc
ces entreprises de chacun réduit de de
l'entropie conjointe et enfin ça peut se
démontrer justement développement cette
expression est donc comme on l'a montré
on a aussi montré qu al khalifa a lancé
ce père et veiller à 0 c'est un conte a
vu tout à l'heure
donc un corollaire de sa colère c'est
que donc ça c'est super eagle à 0 donc
ça veut dire que h2x plus hd y est
supérieur égale hbx il a donc ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
vous ai dit voilà par des cuisses c'est
est ce qu'on à égalité non mon général
tu n'as pas égalité et j'ai même dit que
l'entropie convoité même plus faible que
la somme les entreprises alors là on a
la démonstration est alors enfin un
dernier yoann parce que j'ai plein de
trucs rigolos avec pavon cool
à vern et théorème que le signaler c'est
que l'information mutuelle de x et y
encore une fois on peut jouer avec tout
ça est démontré il savait très bien du
coup nos tropiques 2 x mois l'entropie
2x sachant y ait encore une fois
intuitive ans est très intéressant
samedi
du coup ça aussi c'est que ces supers
cadeaux dont une incertitude sur x et on
apprend y une question intéressante de
savoir c'est à quel point on y va
réduire notre incertitudes sur x c'est
vraiment la fin à sa mutuelle nous dit
exactement cette information c'est
comment l'entretenir l'incertitude sur x
diminuent grâce à l'apprentissage de y
il est des histoires cachées dans tout
ça donc c'est en moyenne tous à
l'information week-end du 18 coups en
moyenne quand j'apprends et serait en en
sachant plus sûr y à quel point je peux
réduire une incertitude sur x puis ça
c'est ultra impertinent dont plein de
points de nos certitudes
ok faire un autre crise la proche des 3
heures tête mois a réussi à faire ça en
vaut trois heures et ça paraît délicat
et sera pas beaucoup puisque trois
heures avec impatience donc le cuir
numéro 8
m
c'est juste une équation de l'éclusé
numéro 8 est ce qu'on a
est-ce qu'on peut aussi dire que
l'information de mutuelle entre les x et
y
c'est l'incertitude sur x y
moi l'incertitude sur x sachant y moins
d'entreprises dans l'incertitude de y
sachons x
alors est-ce parce que vous avez pris
des notes de l'équation que j'ai écrite
mais ça pourra aider
du coup j'ai peut-être les remettre à
l'écran on dit que
e
il est montré les deux premières lignes
l'anjou demande à ce que cette troisième
ligne est vrai nom
[Musique]
je vis toujours de remettre micro
a exigé qu'il ya moins de monde qu'au
début mais il ya deux fois moins
nombreux qu'au début donc c'est pas non
plus comme si ces coûts et parce qu'il
ya beaucoup moins de réponses je sais
pas si c'est quelqu'un qui sont devenus
un peu plus technique
vous êtes donc je danse à savatan d'être
entré pouvoir à 22
[Musique]
ah le live et et l'anglais je suis tête
assez peu trop égoïste à faire des lives
aussi nos jokers fois je vais commencer
à part un peu de théorie d'information
j'étais pas vraiment rentrer dans les
détails
et aussi un côté égoïste parce que ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas fait la
théorie d'information c'est un truc que
j'ai lus en tout 13
alors on fait ça féret ça fait sept ans
et c'est cool comme facebook oubliés du
coup je suis toujours et je suis
régulièrement d'un cadeau avec cette
théorie avec les chercheurs qui n'ont
pas mais j'ai longtemps il n'a pas mis
les mains de danser comme très joli coup
atteint être en présidence
peut-être pas tant qu'il ya du plaisir
c'est beaucoup de temps à les bains
saint crépin ses cinq petites réponses
en plus ça serait cool
de l'épreuve
ouais
or je rembourse pas
la question crs que cette égalité à
troisième qualité là est vrai comment
vous sentez est ce que l'information
mutuelle entre x et y c'est
l'incertitude sûr il y moins
d'incertitudes qu'on aurait en moyenne
si on a mesuré exception ont appris à
vivre avec moi l'incertitude on devine
qu'on a qu'on aurait sur y sur la
présidence
une question est ce que ea de xy est
égal à id y x la réponse est oui en fait
on peut le voir dans la définition qui
donnait tout à leur bonne dans cette
expression il plante son entropie de xy
et égalise dans notre pays de kicks
parce que c'est une incertitude sur la
foi il sait y du coup il s'est expatrié
d'information mutuel c'est la même chose
c'est alors c'est presque sûr quand on
voit cette expression la dire que la
réduction de l'incertitude sur sur x
pour l'apprendre y c'est la même chose
que la réduction de l'incertitude sur
les grecs si on apprend x ça rien de
trivial crise et le temps
c'est cette théorie de la forêt qui me
surprend régulièrement que c'est parce
que les probabilités en général c'est
payer les équations c'est presque
magique que ça soit vrai alors qu'on
pourrait dire c'est une information c
est simple offrir il en fait n'en fait
pas oui mais c'était contre intuitif
bon allez voir têtards et hélas il ya
pas mal moins de réponses
donc voici vos réponses donc à 26
réponse donc ça c'est reparti avec un
petit penchant pour le oui je veux dire
que la moyenne
cette moyenne est à 7
donc si la moyenne est à 7 ça veut dire
que vous aurez plus est si vous êtes
trompés c'est moi moins 1,6 des raisons
ses 6,4 et il se trouve que la réponse
est oui c'est juste marqué 6 4 ce que
fait 18,8 au total donc félicitations
pour faire une démonstration de tout ça
qui va démontrer sa pente de ligne donc
donc on avait déjà vu que hill 2 x y est
égal à acheter x - h x sachant y est on
avait aussi vu que h2x y est égal à bac
2 x + h2y safin qui a sorti de ce x et y
un cercle sur x + incertitudes sur les
grecs sachons x et bien il suffit de
remplacer maintenant
la vie n'est que ça me fait honte par
écrire sur la ch26 moi qui est égal à
acheter xy mois hp y
sachons x des poussins filles de xy
illégal à hx1 y m'ont acheté y sachant x
- hpx sachant ibérique est en fait il ya
une façon de visualiser tout ça qui est
beaucoup plus cools aux oubliettes
je suis partir de ces deux points de
départ quelques montre que c'est ça
venait beaux et bons résultats voyez il
ya une façon assez cool de visualiser
tout ça c'est c'est ce schéma donc le
donc ça c'est h2x c'est l'incertitude
sur x ça c'est alger y la satire sur les
grecs au milieu on trouve là
d'informations qu'on vante l information
nicole temps 10 px y
donc été après cette équation là enfin
cette information cette équation là on
voit que axe de liszt en fait ceux des
composants à l'information mutuelle plus
l'entropie 2x sachant y manque ici en
fait on a acheté x sachant y est de
l'autre côté basse électrique qui
poussait à c y s'a freaks et et voilà et
la somme des ppte de tout ça si je
prends tout ça
c'est un de mes douleurs
si je prends
l'ensemble ça ça va être achetée xy h2x
y ont voient ici c'est l'information
mutuelle plus la partie hp x à shanghai
que sa partie d'alto du rex à chauny ce
dessin permet de retrouver assez
facilement les liens entre ces
différentes variables kun
ok donc c'est de faire une capture
d'écran et moi c'est de garder ça en
tête pour son à passer au prochain
cuisent pour le quizz 9 rapproche peu à
peu des trois heures un peu trop vite
pendant d'abord la cuise neuf textes
les cuisines off c'est quelque chose qui
du coup et va enfin un truc assez
pratique qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est la question bat imaginons qu'on
puisse faire à un seul test t quels
tests faire
en particulier imaginons que ce nous
intéresse c'est l'incertitude sur x et
on veut réduire aux transactions de
l'incertitude sur x et la question c'est
est-ce que la meilleure façon pour
réduire l'incertitude sur x c'est de
choisir le test tai chi maxi qui
maximise l'information mutuelle contre x
et hey est-ce que l'information de
mutuelles c'est la bonne chose à
maximiser quand on choisit un test pour
en savoir plus et pour réduire
l'incertitude on vient dire en savoir
plus sur x
[Musique]
qu'en pensez vous
donc pas partait ce qu'est ce qu'on
entend exactement pourquoi un cas
concret imaginons qu'on veut savoir si
quelqu'un
alko vide on a différentes est possible
par exemple on peut faire le test naso
pharyngé je pense que vous avez vu c'est
une petit jeu au fond du nez on peut
faire le test fécales d'analysé traces
de drm dans le caca
on peut faire il ya des tests par
exemple comment extraits sonores
d'avenir dans les personnes tous
on voit les hearts est possible et
supposons qu'on a les moyens de faire un
seul de ces tests lequel choisir
et une façon de choisir sa voie de dire
bon bah on va choisir le test parmi ceux
là qui maximise l'information mutuelle
entre x et hey ixe xe s'est faite
peut-être que vite postif on était c'est
les résultats du test fonctionne et est
gonflé ce qu'une bonne façon de choisir
les tests c'est de prendre un test qui
maximise l'information mutuelle entre
les knicks étaient en particulier par
bon test j'entends réduire l'incertitude
sur x
alors les quelques milliers de ventes si
j'ai vu passer son email
alors je vais passer mon côté je réponds
souvent sur les i mais là c'est très
compliqué et on voyait des requêtes
c'est assez intéressante mais je sais
c'est donc surtout si le mail est long
et qui demande une réponse élaboré il ya
peu de chance que j'aie le temps en fait
de répondre à cette image visuelle
si c'est une question très simple qui je
crois est pour maintenant
e
oui donc les questions c'est donc c'est
une question grave opposé à ce que pour
réduire l'incertitude sûr et qu'il faut
choisir l'hôtel sûreté vous pouvez
répondre il faut mais les sur se lire là
et ensuite en deux ans des réponses
probabiliste si vous répondez 10 vous
assure que la réponse est oui sur les
réponses des 0 c'est sûr qu'à réponse
est non si vous répondez 5 c'est que
vous avez un état de grande incertitude
et puis voici vous répondez deux ou
trois et vous pensiez pour nous les
consommons silva connaissait tous vite
projeté pour wii et ainsi les 8
e
ce que j'ai fait une vidéo pour dire que
c'est complètement contre intuitif cette
question j'aime les deux vidéos bras sur
la théorie de l'information de leurs
cernes des grands là c'est la raison
pour laquelle je suis en train de faire
cela c'est pour combler ce manque
donc non je n'ai pas parlé de cette
question précise
je vous somme d'informations mutuel
c'est un concept qui prend un peu de
temps qu'elle va être est ce pour ça que
cela et dure trois heures c'est que en
fait je voulais parler d'information
mutuel que ça prend un peu de temps
bon on peut aller voir vos réponses
bref ça mettrait méritera une série de
vidéos sur le sujet mais les vidéos
assez rarement des vidéos de plus de 15
minutes sur
partie principale
on essaye normal ou avec le comique ça
peut plus débordés tel que je devrais
plus débordés en général mais voilà la
vie de trois heures découpé en voir
115,8 fitch a beaucoup d'épisodes sa
parole c'est un peu compliqué ok on peut
passer réponses et les 39 réponse assez
cool ça a augmenté par votre intérieur
et beaucoup de réponses non est un peu
plus répartie il ya l'impression que la
moyenne si la calcul ça serait un ou
deux 2 vient de dire que la moyenne ces
deux donc l'affichage score vous avez
répondu 2 donc si la réponse était en
effet non vous marquerez vous marquez
vivent sur une crête kwc si la réponse
était en fait vrai père des 15,6 points
et la réponse est malheureusement non
pour être franc c'est malheureusement
vrai vous gardez 15 6 pouces rester dans
le positif
mais c'est pas tip top
alors pourquoi est-ce que la réponse est
non en fait on peut voir sur ce graphe
sur ce sur ce dessin que donc réduire
l'incertitude sur x c'est quoi ces h2x
mois h2x ça chante et ça c'est bien une
mesure de la réduction de l'incertitude
et al the x man h2x à chanter c'est
cette partie - cette partie là si je
prends ça et que j'enlève ça il me rase
exactement l'information actuelle x et
du coup si je cherche maintenant à mai
donc si on a envie de réduire
l'incertitude au maximum j'ai envie de
maximiser h2x mois arrivait xd ça
chantait donc ça c'est réduire un
maximum de l'incertitude et ben ça c'est
équivalent à maximiser donc c'est
choisir le test donc c'est ça c'est
servir à maximiser idx j'ai noté du coup
la réponse était oui il faut maximiser
il de x est doté mais c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est à dire que
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur une
chose et c'est vraiment quelque chose de
critiques comme ça après qui apparaît
tout le temps on a plein d'incertitudes
sur plein de choses y compris des sujets
très importants par exemple ce qu'il y
aura un second confinement la façon de
réduire cette incertitude c'est de
chercher des tests qui ont une grande en
formation mutuelle avec mixité
et sur ce qu'on va finir avec le dernier
cuisent le dernier cuisent
un peu plus de trois heures
car le dernier cuisine dit ça
ty
l'information mutuelle entre deux
variables réel est grande et ainsi
variables réel et grande terre si leur
formation mutuelle entre x y et proche
de l'entropie convainc xy
alors ces deux variables sont fortement
corrélés c'est la dernière
c'est pour cette dernière dernière pour
la route
est-ce que grande information mutuelle
implique une grande corrélation
qu'en pensez vous
[Musique]
information mutuelle implique
corrélation sachant que corrélation
n'implique pas causalité ça a à voir
avec la question c'est toujours bon de
le rappeler
plus
e
donc soit on entend par variable corps
il est donc la définition de la
corrélation une variable réel c'est que
suivant 6 x est grand alors y est grand
aussi ça serait une corrélation positive
fortement qu elle ça peut être
négativement aussi il sait grand alors y
est petit c'est ça être fortement
corrélés c'est soit corrélation positive
soit corée sont négatives
mais quand l'information mutuelle entre
x et y y
alors forcément quand il sait qu on y
est grand aussi
ou quand ils ces écrans y est très
faible
[Musique]
ouais j'aurais dû préciser corps et les
gens tentent possible négativement
il
ah les autres sujets à une question sur
as que je compte faire des vidéos sur
les autres sujets que j'avais proposé à
un moment ça crée beaucoup de sujets et
est la réponse malheureusement a en tout
cas pas dans un futur et celle de trois
ans
je sais que les gens ont peut-être un
peu marre que je parle de belize mais
l'essai surveille à l'isf est un fan qui
est encore tellement de choses à dire il
faut pas parler de solomonoff que j'ai
même pas parler de temps de la place
encore un petit peu ne va pas beaucoup
il ya encore tellement de choses à dire
sur le bail à nice mme le principe de
précaution par exemple j'ai une liste de
sujets extrêmement longue et donc quels
sont les sujets que courtiser un peu
quelques sujets cool que j'avais prévu
il y voyait vend énormément de choses et
du bon enfin non seulement j'adore
balzani asie mais en plus de ça je pense
que c'est vraiment un sujet important et
qui aviez besoin de bien débroussaillé
tout ça donc pas besoin je perds que
pays''
encore là il ya encore beaucoup de
sujets médias locaux vides à finir enfin
encore beaucoup de choses à dire sur
co-lead donc alors rasoir d'occam du
toit préparer le rasoir d'occam qu'il
est incroyable à dire sur la zone de
calmes
elle n'oublie science logique c'est un
sujet important les contrefactuelle très
critique
le paradoxe de stein qui est génial
les marchés prédictifs aussi à des trucs
intéressants à dire sur le consensus
scientifique aussi être utilisé à 120
dire sur la rationalité avait prévu de
dire des trucs mais dont ils gênent
mental a fait sa vidéo je vais pas le
faire ça
il était incollable sur le biais de
confirmation bayésiens de l'argument
d'autorité balisé aussi c'est l'étoile
incroyable qui juste change ma façon de
voir le monde en parle
le débat buy vient à l'article
incroyable de skatar donne sur un an les
débats veille un séjour à bord
tiens il ya encore beaucoup de choses à
dire malheureusement jeu
il peut repartir sur peut-être que je
ferais pose dans des alcôves idées non
plus une pause du pays puis sinon un
autre gros sujet du moment c'est un peu
plus les titres qu'ils avaient des
algorithmes et
en fait les mathématiques de l'éthique
c'est un sujet que je trouve absolument
génial que qui est très peu connue et
très peu abordée finances de trucs
vraiment incroyable a raconté
ceci il ait de bonnes chances de jeu
tease un peu un truc
voilà d'entre nous que 164 mari qui sont
restés jusque là il reste bien quelques
secrets
mais ryan ya un projet que j'ai de
nouveau enseigner un cours de
mathématiques de l'éthique euros
deux philosophies algorithmique et façon
de dire dans ces tares section bompas
et du coup il ya ce cours sera pas très
clair encore dans quel cadre ce cours
sera donné
mais peut-être que ce sera du coup un
truc diffusé voilà peu rare donc un bon
coup
du coup il y aura sans doute
possiblement beaucoup de contenu qui
sera du coup de moindre qualité divers
divertissante audiovisuelle mais qui
sera le préfet
et regarde regard y ait encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes et beaucoup d'intérêt
il pousse pas les choses a trop dire
bref pas les dire là c'est encore
souvent c'est pas du tout dit c'est
encore très très très ok on va passer à
la correction voilà du 24 réponse à la
question est ce que l'information
mutuelle un pic corrélation et vous
pencher vers le oui je pense qu'en
moyenne et tout mais de dire si ce sont
en moyenne on va dire 6 de moyenne
donc si je mets moyenne à pons à 6 il se
trouve que la réponse dans ce cas était
en fête
poss et du coup on finit avec un mois
4,4
ce qui fait que la catastrophe
finissez dans le négatif fait c'est pas
tip top
dire que vous faites moins bien que le
hasard ça veut surtout dire qu' il ya
des seront globalement
mal juger du degré de confiance adéquat
avoir été un peu à un excès de confiance
hier que si vous avez pensé des moments
drôles de même côté mais avec des
réponses beaucoup plus proche de 5
vous auriez pu finalement positif parce
qu'en fait les valeurs extrêmes sont
extrêmement pénalisé des questions de
fausses donc pas fait pire que lui a
versé c'est pas tip top
alors c'est très difficile de raisonner
de façon probabilité de voir
travaillistes mais je pense que c'est
vraiment vraiment important dans le jeu
j'ai envie de vous encourager à
davantage raisonner de façon probable à
moins penchée vers les extrêmes et pour
cela je vous recommande le lebel up
le le le site web pays tire est à point
ap
développé par lui faut qu'on vous avez
vraiment y aller à vous entraîner à me
répondre et les qcm rigolo et puis ça
s'habituer à raisonner - de façon
extrême qui est très difficile c'est pas
du tout avec ce qu'on a
et mais en fait si on répond juste façon
instinctive à cqcm by their en fait on
est très très mauvaise parce qu'on est
juste très mauvais avec les profiter
parce qu'on a tendance à beaucoup trop
exagérée elle beaucoup trop dans l'excès
de confiance
et quand il s'agit de questions de maths
à la limite on s'en fout mais quand il
s'agit de questions de société c'est un
énorme énorme problème donc développé
beaucoup plus ce raisonnement provisy à
se rendre compte qu'on est très très
mauvais instinctivement avec les
probabilités a jugé de l'entropie que
l'on a par rapport à différentes étapes
du monde ou à différentes données
se rendre compte que cette entropie on
l'a sous-estiment beaucoup c'est je
pense que c'est une partie importante
l'apprentissage qui est malheureusement
un peu trop
voilà en tout cas je vais finir quand
même pas vous expliquer pourquoi est-ce
que ce informations mutuelle d'un pic
pas corrélées corrélation et je peux
vous expliquer très simplement avec un
graphe ce graphe au ce graphe là donc si
on à dépendre si si si ça c'est xy et on
tire xy aléatoirement les laiteries qui
sont pile sur cette courbe là et bien là
à ce moment là on aurait un cas où
l'information mutuelle sur x et y est
maximal auquel est égal à acheter xy
c'est à dire que si on connaît x koné y
question koné ibrahim koné x parce qu'on
veut c'est qu'on est sûr cette droite
visionner x c'est pas très bon il
raconté
en fait c'est une bêtise que je raconte
donc c'est pas tout à fait ça que je
raconte ce pad ça fait l'exemple médias
on est juste des bouts de corde
ça fait un bon exemple mais bon c'est
quasiment un bon exemple
on a des bouts de corde comme ça et
andreu a cédé verticale comme ça
s'applique r
ok allons désolé c'est clair
on va donc lada saint quentin le
meilleur exemple donc on exactement
quelque part sur ces chaque fois qu'on
tire x et y
on est exactement mais sur ces bouts de
doigts des fois que c'est que quand on
connait x on sait exactement y est quand
on connait y on connaît exactement x
donc l'information mutuelle entre les
deux est maximal légal de votre pays on
vante et dans ce cas ben y'a pas
corrélation parce que parce que la
coalition c'est une tendance quand il
s'est fait à blur y est faible ou vice
versa en fait l'information mutuelle un
code beaucoup plus précisément ce qu'on
entend par l'information de x h on y est
a fortiori grec socialiste de lien entre
les deux alors qu'un correction c'est
juste la tendance c'est juste une
tendance du premier ordre
mais cette équipe a des liens plus faim
qu'il pourrait y avoir entre x y et qui
me permettrait de connaître y sachant x
donc c'est cette notion d'information
est beaucoup plus fondamentale en fait
que la corrélation
c'est ici je pourrai exprès de pas mal
de manière mais cette notion
d'information avait beaucoup beaucoup
plus fondamentale la corrélation c'est
un truc à la baby toujours nous dire
mais bien produit théorie d'information
truc fondamental c'est l'information
c'est beaucoup plus fondamentale et
j'espère vous avoir fait les sentiers
c'est au moins un petit peu à quel point
cette théorie de l'information et
centrale et nous dit des choses vraiment
très profonde sur l'information sur
l'incertitude sur ce que c'est de savoir
sur comment réduire cette ignorance
comment décrire cette hargne cette
ignorance qui et comment comparer
l'ignorance de deux modèles de
respectifs et les liens que ça avec kate
est priorisée avec comme encoder
l'information comment communiquer tout
ça est incroyablement profond et
aujourd'hui c'était juste une
introduction mais enfin la théorie de
l'information c'est vraiment un
croisement profonde et c'est surtout
incroyablement beau rythme est vraiment
quelque chose de magnifique derrière la
théorie de l'information
on a juste est gratinée la surface et
bat j'espère que ça vous a motivée en
savoir plus et foncez m'en aller plus
haut auquel je vous remercie beaucoup de
vos participations c'était un bon mois
ça va être beaucoup à m'intéresser à
nouveau à ce sujet à ce que c'est beau
c'est sûr notion de puces de vous avoir
ici donc je vous remercie et pour ce
moment aussi très très sympa et je vous
dit probablement une prochaine fois
parce que je pense que ça me plait
suffisamment pour pour commencer c'est
lors de la sortie vous dis au revoir et
à bientôt pour la vie la vidéo de lundi
qu'il parlait pas mal aussi
d'informations et de probabilités tokyo